Sie sehen nicht wirklich das neue Medium, das sie aufrücken. Sie denken an das alte Medium, weil das alte Medium immer der Content des neuen Mediums ist, denn die Filme sind die Content der TV, und die Buchse sind die Content der Novels, die Content der Filme. Und so, wenn das neue Medium kommt, ist das alte Medium das Content, und es ist sehr beobachtend, sehr bemerkenswert, dass es nicht möglich ist, das zu machen.
Ihr hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 203. Ausgabe von CRE. Es gab mal wieder eine längere kreative Schaffenspause, aber wie das immer so ist, irgendwann fällt einem auch mal wieder was ein. Und ja, so ist es jetzt gekommen. Und ich habe jetzt mal ein Thema ausgesucht, was fast schon zu naheliegend ist, wenn man sich mit dem Internet beschäftigt und auch so auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen verspricht, dass es so vielfältig ist, dass man es gar nicht so richtig fassen kann. Alles werden wir jetzt mal sehen. Es geht um Journalismus. Konkreter geht es um Online-Journalismus, sprich, was bringt die Internet-Komponente an der Stelle eigentlich Neues mit ein. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner Stephan Dörner. Ja, Stephan, du bist auch ein bisschen ein Kind des Netzes, oder? Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, also ich bin nicht direkt mit dem Internet aufgewachsen.
Ein bisschen näher, genau.
Wie jetzt die echte Generation der Digital Natives, wo ich ja gerade noch so mit dem Geburtsjahr 82 reinfalle, ich hatte das Internet ab 2000, glaube ich, zu Hause. Und vorher musste ich dann immer zur Uni fahren oder zu anderen Stellen, Internet-Cafés, wo ich mich dann im Netz austoben konnte. Also ich konnte meine Eltern erst im Jahr 2000 davon überzeugen, dass wir Internet brauchen.
Ja gut, aber bis dahin hat es zumindest eine gewisse Zeit gehabt, schon zu reifen. Das ist ja auch von Vorteil. Aber dann bist du relativ schnell reingehüpft da in den Zaubertrank.
Ja, genau. Ich hab eigentlich schon direkt dann mit dem Internet zu Hause auch angefangen zu bloggen, auch wenn es damals auch nicht so hieß. Mit einer eigenen Website. Darf man heute keinem mehr zeigen, was ich damals so vor mir gegeben hab, glaube ich, ist auch jetzt schon längst verschwunden.
Ja, das ist so wie der erste Podcast.
Genau.
Man muss dann aber mutig sein und die trotzdem online halten.
Ich glaube, der Host ist schon lange pleite, wo ich das damals gehorcht hab. Geocities oder was? Nee, nee, Geocities. Das war schon vorbei. Das war in den 90er Jahren. Stimmt.
Und heute bist du ja, kann man das so sagen, Journalist?
Ja.
Auch mit Siegel und Stempel so?
Genau, mit Pressausweis und offizieller Lizenz. Also der Begriff Journalist ist ja in Deutschland aus guten Gründen nicht geschützt. Seit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Das heißt, jeder kann sich Journalist nennen.
Was sind die guten Gründe dafür?
Also in der Nazizeit muss man Mitglied der Reichskammer für Journalisten oder irgendwie so was sein, damit man die offizielle Lizenz hat, Journalist zu sein. Und seitdem hat man gelernt und jetzt darf sich jeder Journalist nennen.
Das kann natürlich auch Nachteile haben.
Ja, klar, aber ich sehe es wirklich eher positiv, weil Journalist sein hat für mich nichts damit zu tun, ob jetzt irgendwer bei einem Verlag arbeitet oder so, sondern das hat damit zu tun, ob man sorgfältig arbeitet, ob man einen ausgewogenen Bericht erstattet und gewisse Standards einhält. Das kann ja im Grunde jeder, also dafür braucht man keine offizielle Ausweisung und es gibt dadurch auch Journalisten, die sich auch nicht an diese Standards halten, also von daher finde ich das ganz in Ordnung.
Also wie Kraftwerk sagt, jeder kann elektronische Musik machen, sagt du, jeder kann Journalist sein.
Das sagt auch das Gesetz.
Vielleicht sogar ich.
Also du könntest hier glaube ich auch einen Presseausweis holen. Also da ist nur die Voraussetzung, dass man überwiegend sein Einkommen aus journalistischer Tätigkeit erbringt.
Ja gut, das ist die Definitionsfrage, was ist eine journalistische Tätigkeit. Aber da wollen wir ja mit gewisser Hinsicht auch hinaus, aber du hast trotzdem auch ein bisschen Ausbildung schon betrieben, du hast jetzt nicht einfach angefangen, dich Journalist zu nennen und gut ist.
Ich habe keine klassische Journalistenschule besucht, ich habe ein Studium absolviert, Politikwissenschaften, Medienwissenschaften und Soziologie und habe während des Studiums schon ein Praktikum gemacht, also mehrere Praktika und eins auch beim Handelsblatt und da habe ich dann auch als freier Journalist schon während des Studiums gearbeitet und dann als Pauschalist danach und irgendwann fest angestellt.
Als Pauschalist?
Ja, Pauschalist heißt, du bist nicht angestellt, aber du arbeitest regelmäßig für einen festen Betrag in der Redaktion. Das heißt, ich habe keine klassischen Journalistenschule und Ausbildung genossen.
Du hast ja gesagt, du hast als erstes einen Blog aufgemacht, sogar einen Blog-Hoster aufgemacht.
Ja, das auch, ja. Später dann, 2007.
Den gibt es aber nicht mehr.
Den gibt es nicht mehr. Das war blogage.de. Da war die Idee, Bloggen so einfach wie möglich zu machen. Da habe ich auch bei meinem ersten Blog-Posting zu diesem neuen Blog-Hoster berechtsradiotheorie zitiert. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das was sagt, aber...
Jeder ist ein Sender.
Genau. Und das war so ein bisschen die Vision, jeden zum Sender zu machen. Und die Vision ist auch gelungen, aber nicht uns. Das ist dann Anna gelungen wie Tumblr.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist jetzt die Frage, weil das ist ja nun eigentlich gerade so diese goldene Zeit gewesen, so 2004, 2006. Ich erinnere mich ausgerechnet an diese paar Jahre in dieser ganzen Internetgeschichte immer ganz gut, weil die eigentlich eine totale Umwälzung waren. Vorher bedeutete eigentlich Öffentlichsein im Internet immer eine Webseite haben, so. Und der Sprung von eine Webseite haben oder keine Webseite haben zu eine Webseite haben war irgendwie sehr groß. Der wurde auch immer gerne als extrem schwierig dahingestellt. Davon hat ja eine gewisse Start-up-Kultur auch lange Zeit sehr gut gelebt. Da wurden ja für irgendwie aber Millionen irgendwie wenige HTML-Seiten mit irgendwelchen...
Jeder, der eine.com-Adresse anmelden konnte, war millionär.
Ja, genau. Also es war einfach auch ein bisschen albern. Zumindest so für die alten Hasen, die da immer so draufblicken und eigentlich den ganzen Tag nur den Kopf schütteln konnten. Aber das ist ja in dem Sinne nicht ausgeblieben. Kommt immer wieder was vorbei, worüber man auch nicht den Kopf schütteln kann. Nichtsdestotrotz kam ja dieser Begriff des Bloggens auf und damit dann auch so mit diesen ersten Tools, movable type und also die ersten Blogplattformen, später dann WordPress und wie sie alle hießen, kam dann ja auch relativ schnell so diese Diskussion auf so, hm, auf einmal ist das jetzt einfach, hier, ich klick mir mal da so einen Blog und dann fange ich da an zu schreiben und dann bin ich dann schon so im Internet und so und ich weiß noch, als ich selber meine ersten Klimmzüge da gemacht habe, einfach mal angefangen habe, so bei mich irgendwas zu schreiben, kamen auch so Freunde auf mich zu und so, ja, also was du da so schreibst und so, das ist ja schon sehr persönlich und so und das ist alles sehr interessant irgendwie, aber hast du da nicht Bedenken und was nicht anderes? Ich will es jetzt nicht auf diese Privatschutz, Datenschutz oder sonst wie Social-Me-Diskussion heben, so aber man hat einfach gemerkt, dass diese Veränderung, diese technische Veränderung dann eben auch automatisch Leute dazu gebracht hat, vorbei an allen Gatekeeper zu agieren.
Ja, ich hab das damals nicht so erlebt, dass die Blogger jetzt den Klatschen Journalismus so stark herausgefordert haben. Also wenn man sich heute mal Zulüfzahlen anguckt von den großen Blogs, das ist immer noch weltentfernt von den Nachrichtenseiten. Also hinzu kommt ja, dass Online-Werbung, was ja momentan das einzige wirklich funktionierende Geschäftsmodell ist in Deutschland für Online-Journalismus, sich erst abgewissen, Klickzahlen eben lohnt. Also das ist so ein reines Massengeschäft eigentlich bisher, obwohl es das nicht sein müsste. Man könnte da über Spitze Zielgruppen und sowas alles reden, aber so wie es de facto umgesetzt wird, ist es so, dass die Blogs einfach leider kein Geld verdienen.
Es gibt auch Ausnahmen, so ist es ja nicht, ne?
Ja, es gibt Ausnahmen, sind aber nicht wirklich journalistische Formate, würde ich sagen. Also es gibt auch bei YouTube und so weiter, da gibt es ja diese ganzen Mr. Tutorials und so, wo dann irgendwie Werbung und Redaktionen vermischt wird und das funktioniert dann auch. Und es gibt ja so Produktreview-Blogs und so was, wo das vielleicht auch funktioniert, wo man dann auch so ein bisschen in diesen Bereich kommt, wo das sich vermischt. Aber zum Beispiel ein richtig erfolgreiches Blog, was redaktionell gut geführt ist, ist ja Netzpolitik zum Beispiel und die machen ja eher Verlust noch unterm Stich. Haben sie ja auch kürzlich mal öffentlich gemacht, was sie da eigentlich alles reinstecken und was sie rausbekommen. Und obwohl sie eigentlich eine relativ hohe Reichweite haben für einen Blog, also für einen Blog sogar eine sehr große Reichweite, können sie das nicht ummünzen in wirklich ein funktionierendes Geschäftsmodell.
Würdest du das unter Journalismus führen? netzpolitik.org?
Ja, ein bisschen schon, das stimmt. Das ist auf jeden Fall kein klassischer Journalismus, aber es finden zumindest journalistische Elemente statt. Also man sieht ja zum Beispiel, dass Leute Markus Becketal vertrauen, weil er dann Scoops hat, weil ihm Leute halt Sachen herantragen. Das heißt, es gibt Leute, die davon ausgehen, dass er damit gut umgeht und deswegen ihm das anvertrauen. Das ist für mich schon ein Zeichen dafür, dass es jemand ist, der sich eine Reputation aufgebaut hat. Und das gehört auch zum Journalismus dazu. Klar, er ist natürlich nicht der klassische neutrale Berichterstatter, das auf keinen Fall, weil er selber aktivistisch auch aktiv ist. Von daher würde ich auch sagen, es ist jetzt kein klassisches journalistisches Format, aber es hat schon journalistische Elemente auf jeden Fall.
Aber was ist denn dann sozusagen jetzt klassisch Journalismus? Also du hast ja eben schon so ein bisschen gesagt, was für dich so die, was einen dazu macht, Journalist zu sein. Vielleicht noch mal daran anschließend, was ist deine Erwartung an Journalismus jetzt im Allgemeinen? Was hat dieses Genre oder dieser Ausriss aus unserer Gesellschaft zu leisten? Was ist sozusagen hier Anspruch?
Da muss ich glaube ich schon direkt zum Anfang der Sendung ein bisschen philosophisch werden, wenn du schon sagst. Nur zu. Ich glaube, dass Menschen ein bisschen in Geschichten denken. Also generell, wenn sie die Realität konstruieren, wir können ja nicht die gesamte Komplexität der Realität wirklich erfassen, sondern wir müssen ja immer irgendwelche Muster haben, durch die wir die Realität erfassen. Und Geschichten sind da eigentlich schon immer so einen Weg gewesen, wie man die Realität irgendwie reduziert und damit erfassen kann. Und ich glaube, Journalisten haben ein bisschen die Aufgabe, das, was passiert in der Welt, in der Gesellschaft, in der Politik, in der Wirtschaft so aufzuschreiben, dass daraus Geschichten werden, dass sie erfassbar werden. Das heißt, sie müssen Komplexität reduzieren und damit haben sie eigentlich eine sehr verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe, weil man muss ja dann was weglassen, wenn man Komplexität reduziert. Und dann sehe ich die Aufgaben von Journalisten so, dass er eben nichts Wesentliches weglässt an dieser Geschichte, dass er alle relevanten Seiten anfragt und ihre Sicht der Dinge darstellen lässt im Artikel. Und somit eben auf verantwortungsvolle Weise die Komplexität, die wir nicht erfassen können, so weit runterbricht, dass sie für jemanden erfassbar ist, der sich nicht jeden Tag mit diesem Thema komplett beschäftigt. So würde ich das vielleicht mal kurz... Das ist jetzt keine Medientheorie oder so, sondern das ist jetzt meine persönliche Auffassung.
Erfassbar für jeden ist natürlich...
Oder ja, für jeden ist natürlich ein bisschen hoch der Anspruch, vielleicht, sagen wir mal, für das Zielpuppenkumpel, das man dann natürlich schreibt.
Jetzt ist Journalismus in der Hinsicht dann so doch eine sehr traditionelle Einrichtung geworden über die Zeit. Irgendwann war das halt mal neu und über lange, lange Zeit waren das halt Zeitungen, war es halt Schreiben. Ich glaube, wir werden ja heute auch so ein bisschen so den Fokus, glaube ich, auf das Schreiben haben, obwohl natürlich letztlich da genauso das Fernsehen und Radio natürlich auch im Prinzip im selben Wald wildert. Und durch das Internet gibt es jetzt einfach eine ganze Reihe von Umbrüchen. Wir erleben das ja in der täglichen politischen Debatte, wo dieser Journalismus als solcher auf einmal so am Pranger steht. Also noch so in den 70er Jahren, Spiegel-Affäre und solche Geschichten war so der Journalismus. Und dann eben vor allem natürlich noch so bestimmte Publikationen innerhalb dieser Landschaft waren so die Hironen der Freiheit, die Bewahrer, die Beschützer unseres Systems, auch sturmgeschützte der Demokratie. Soweit ging das. Und das Bild scheint an vielen Stellen zu bröckeln. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt nur am Internet liegt. Das ist sicherlich nicht die einzige Debatte. Aber das spielt natürlich dann auch eine bestimmte Rolle, zumindest jetzt für diese Online. Auch die Unabhängigkeit und die Verwebung so mit kapitalistischen Strukturen war natürlich auch schon immer ein Thema.
Ja, Springer's Bild wurde jetzt auch schon in den 60ern stark angegriffen. Also einzelne Medien standen natürlich schon immer auch in der Kritik.
Was hat sich jetzt sozusagen verändert? Das ist meine Frage.
Ich habe mal vor kurzem getwittert, bei Jugendlichen haben Verlage inzwischen ein ähnliches Image wie Pharmaindustrie und Waffenlobby. Also dank Leistungsschutzrecht und so weiter. Es ist natürlich eine Branche, die durch die Umbrüche irgendwie gefährdet ist. Und als alteingesetzene Branche, die durch Neuheiten gefährdet ist, übt man sich ganz gerne mal in Abwehrreflexen gegen das Neue. Und so nehme ich das teilweise auch bei den Verlagen wahr. Und so nehmen es auch viele Menschen wahr, durch eben solche unsinnigen Gesetze wie das Leistungsschutzrecht. Dabei hinaus ist natürlich durch das Internet zum ersten Mal so eine Art Parallelöffentlichkeit geschaffen worden, sodass eben die Gatekeeper-Funktion der Medien nicht mehr so komplett wirkt. Das heißt, was wir jetzt erleben, ist, wenn irgendwer sich in einem Interview nicht richtig wiedergegeben fühlt, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Marina Weisband mit der Spiegelgeschichte, dann schreibt sie in ihrem Blog eben eine Gegendarstellung direkt und braucht einfach gar nicht mehr das Medium dafür und verbreitet das über ihre sozialen Medien. Wobei sie natürlich jetzt auch die Möglichkeit hat, durch die vielen Follower und so weiter da zurückzuschlagen. Aber im Prinzip hat das ja erst mal jeder, zumindest seine Sicht der Dinge zu veröffentlichen und dann eben auch zu verbreiten. Und ich glaube, dadurch ist so ein bisschen auch der Schleier gelüftet über diesem Mysterium-Journalismus, weil man eben da auch dann ganz oft hinter die Kulissen blicken kann und eben sehen kann, dass das eben nur eine Sicht der Dinge ist, auch wenn Journalismus gerne so als vom hohen Ross und neutraler Perspektive daherkommt. Also ich glaube, das hat so ein bisschen das entmystifiziert auch. Den Journalismus und den Anspruch, den Journalisten, oft dann vor sich hergetragen haben in der Vergangenheit. Und wie gesagt, die Verlage werden natürlich unter jungen, internetaffinen Leuten oft als negativ wahrgenommen, einfach weil sie ihre Fälle ein bisschen davon schwimmen sehen durch die Veränderung und da eben auch mit Lobbyismus reagieren, mit dem Versuch, Gesetze durchzudrücken, die dann Veränderungszahlen aufhalten sollen, was natürlich auch nicht wirklich funktionieren kann.
Ja, es ist eigentlich ganz interessant, dass man ja eigentlich gerade von Journalisten erwarten würde, dass sie so Veränderungen in der Gesellschaft gut wahrnehmen. Da man ja sozusagen eigentlich den Anspruch hat, alles zu beobachten und darüber zu berichten, wie es sich ändert und eben Veränderungen auch transparent zu machen, zu erklären etc. Und ausgerechnet dann bei der Veränderung der eigenen Basis scheint es manchmal nicht zu funktionieren.
Da muss man natürlich auch ein bisschen trennen zwischen den Journalisten und denen, die die Verlage in der Geschäftsführungsebene bestimmen. Das sind eben keine Journalisten, sondern das sind BWLer. Und BWLer, ich muss jetzt vorsichtig sein, was ich sage. Man sagt sie jetzt nicht dafür bekannt, dass sie eine besonders breite Wahrnehmung haben von dem, was in der Gesellschaft passiert, sondern sie fokussieren sich sehr stark auf Zahlen und Geschäftszahlen. Und sie sehen eben, dass das Geschäft der Verlage durch diese Veränderung auf jeden Fall eine starke Veränderung unterworfen ist. Und die auch erstmal aus reinen Geschäftsperspektiven negativ ist.
Das heißt, man muss jetzt vielleicht in dieser ganzen Debatte auch mal so ein bisschen trennen zwischen den Begriffen. So Journalismus als Sammelbegriff für die Journalisten und ihre Berichterstattung versus die den Journalismus ermöglichenden und leitenden Strukturen wie Verlage und größere Konzerne, die da noch mal quasi ihr eigenes Wesen treiben. Aber die Journalisten werden dann immer sozusagen dafür abgestraft. Findest du das gerechtfertigt?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Die Debatte ist das so, du bist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch selber betroffen. Du schreibst jetzt selber, du arbeitest als Journalist, du bist selber, verstehst dich denke ich auch mal im Wesentlichen als, du machst eigentlich nur online, oder?
Also das Medium, für das ich jetzt arbeite, das Wall Street Journal Deutschland, das ist rein digital und davor war ich beim Handelsblatt in der Online-Redaktion und da sind zwar am Artikel von mir im Print erschienen, aber ich habe auch überwiegend für online gearbeitet.
Jetzt hast du natürlich diesen Wechsel, in dem du gar nicht mitgemacht hast, weil du bist ja da quasi nie anders aufgestellt gewesen. Ist das für dich ein Vorteil eigentlich?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also ich glaube, ja, es ist insofern ein Vorteil, dass ich einfach von vornherein mit diesen Veränderungen gerechnet habe und mich darauf eingestellt habe und jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag greine, dass nicht mehr alles so ist wie früher. Also das ist vielleicht schon ein Vorteil insofern.
Also an der Stelle bist du dann schon digital nativ quasi?
Ja, genau. Also was Journalismus angeht, bin ich digital nativ. Ich habe vor dem digitalen Zeitalltag keinen Journalismus.
Aber du findest es trotzdem eine reizvolle Position, also eine reizvolle Tätigkeit. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass du so, ah, scheiße, ich bin 20 Jahre zu spät gekommen, ist ja alles gar nicht mehr so toll.
Also das Leben für Journalisten war sicherlich mal einfacher, muss man schon so sagen. Also was Arbeitszeiten, Bezahlung, Sicherheit im Job und so weiter angeht, das war sicherlich deutlich bequemer, als die Verlage noch zweistellige Renditen durch die Bank eingefahren haben.
Und es war bei Siemens bestimmt auch schon mal besser, ja?
Ja.
Also das ist ja nicht die einzige Branche, die jetzt sozusagen solche Auswirkungen erleidet.
Nee, aber ich glaube, dieser Umbruch ist im Journalismus schon auch stärker, man merkt das auch schon stärker an der Generation der jungen Journalisten, dass sich dieser Umbruch da vorzogen hat, auch im Selbstverständnis. Also wenn man jetzt mit älteren Journalisten spricht, die schon länger dabei sind und lange Print mitgemacht haben, die haben noch so einen ganz anderen Nimbus um sich oder die sehen Journalismus noch so als im Elfenbeinturm und über den Menschen schwebend und die Welt erklärend und der Pöbel soll mal bitte nicht unbedingt seine Magen dazu abgeben, ist oft so das, was diese Leute so ausstrahlen und da hat sich schon sehr, sehr stark was verändert, glaube ich.
Und wie würdest du das für dich beschreiben? Wie siehst du dich sozusagen als Online-Journalist oder als Journalist der modernen Zeit sozusagen innerhalb der Gesellschaft?
Ich würde sagen, ich bin einfach zugänglicher beispielsweise als die alten Journalisten. Also ich bin auf Twitter aktiv und jeder kann mich antwittern und jeder kann sich beschweren über Artikel von mir, jeder kann mir eine E-Mail schreiben oder in den Kommentaren schreiben und ich werde das auch lesen, ich werde darauf eingehen und ich sage nicht von vornherein, ich habe die Wahrheit gepachtet, weil ich weiß, das hat keiner und versuche einfach so ein bisschen prozessorientierter auch zu arbeiten, also nicht nur einfach irgendwas schreiben und das ist dann fertig und das steht dann im Netz und so ist es, sondern eben dann auch auf Feedback eingehen und so weiter und das ist ein bisschen als Work in Progress zu betrachten.
Das heißt, du leidest nicht nur nicht unter Feedback, sondern du betrachtest es als Teil des Prozesses, also dir würde was fehlen, wenn es nicht kommen würde.
Genau, ja.
Was leistet dann das Feedback für dich an der Stelle?
Es gibt mir eine Einordnung. Ich bin ja auch kein Experte auf allen Gebieten. Journalisten leben ja davon, dass sie Experten kommunizieren und dann sozusagen verschiedene Meinungen zusammenfassen und wiedergeben und in diesem Prozess gibt es immer wieder natürlich Leute, die Wertvolles in ihrer Perspektive von außen nochmal dazu beisteuern können, weil ich mich einfach nicht jeden Tag mit den Themen beschäftige, über die ich schreibe, sondern immer mal wieder und von daher gibt es einfach immer Leute, die es besser wissen und mich darauf hinweisen können, wo Fehler gemacht werden zum Beispiel.
Jetzt ist ja die ganze Branche offensichtlich in einem Aufbruch, teilweise laufen diese Prozesse auch schon länger. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir 2013, gerade eben nochmal nachgeschlagen, seit wann es Spiegel Online gibt, das sind jetzt schon fast 20 Jahre, das muss man sich auch irgendwie mal klar machen. Und ich weiß auch noch, was das für ein Ereignis war, als dann der Spiegel auf einmal im Internet auftauchte. Also, hm, hier guck mal, neue Webseite und so, Spiegel ist jetzt auch dabei. Das ist natürlich überhaupt gar kein Vergleich zu dem, was wir da heute sehen, was so die Schlagzahl betrifft, etc. Aber zumindest war das schon mal so ein Aha-Moment, wo man dachte so, okay, alles klar, da ist zumindest irgendjemand, der so ein bisschen begriffen hat, dass da die neue Relevanz zu entstehen scheint, so wie es ja dann letztlich auch kam. Mit der Zeit kamen dann andere hinterher, trotzdem ist es irgendwie immer noch so ein Klagelied. Man hat immer noch das Gefühl, man müsste die ganze Zeit Händchen halten und Kehrpakete da hinschicken, um alle irgendwie bei Laune zu halten. Also es ist ein furchtbares Gejammer, finde ich, was sich da so über die Jahre immer wieder entwickelt hat, was auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen dazu beigetragen hat, dass man irgendwie auch so wenig Nachsicht hat, wenn sie sich beklagen über Feedback oder Beklagen über alles, einfach für die ganze Zeit nur gejammert. Das ist wahrscheinlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine sehr deutsche Tugend in der Wahrnehmung. Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt so …Ja, in den USA wurde auch viel gejammert. Ja, aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass da auch noch ein bisschen mehr Mut und Selbstverständlichkeit herrscht, was das Digitale betrifft. Da können wir ja gleich auch nochmal drauf kommen bzw. da wollte ich jetzt eigentlich auch gerade drauf kommen. Es gibt ja nun verschiedene Online-Formate, die sich entwickelt haben und es gibt auch sehr viele Unterschiede in der Art und Weise, wie journalistische Unternehmen da herangegangen sind. Was würdest du denn jetzt so als die wichtigsten bzw. am interessantesten Modelle herausnehmen, wo man jetzt mal sehen kann, was denn überhaupt gewagt wurde und wie gut das funktioniert hat?
Ja, da ist man ein bisschen im Dilemma als jemand, der Fan ist von digitalen Formaten, weil es gibt gewisse journalistische Publikationen, besonders will ich ja vorheben den Guardian, der sehr stark dieses Online-Medium eben nutzt als Online-Medium und all diese Möglichkeiten, die das Online-Medium bietet, ausnutzt. Ein Beispiel, als die Riots waren in England, da sind die Reporter auf die Straße gegangen mit ihren Smartphones, haben auf der Karte markiert, wo sie gerade sind, haben Live-Journalismus betrieben mit den Smartphones. Man konnte eben sehen im Video-Livestream, was da gerade passiert. Es wurde verbunden mit den sozialen Medien und so weiter, also die sind sehr, sehr innovativ auch in ihren Darstellungsformen, es gibt ganz viel Daten-Journalismus beim Guardian, es gibt einen Blog, der genau darüber aufklärt, wie sie arbeiten und wo dann Feedback eingeholt wird. Das heißt, sie machen also wirklich eine ganze Menge richtig und sie sind auch insofern erfolgreich, dass sie viele Leser damit erreichen. Also sie sind nach New York Times und ich glaube noch irgendein anderes britisches Medium sind sie auf Platz drei im Bereich englischsprachiger Medien, noch vor der BBC weltweit und haben inzwischen auch mehr Leser in den USA als in Großbritannien im Heimatmarkt, aber sind eben damit finanziell absolut nicht erfolgreich, sondern sie machen riesige Verluste und werden querfinanziert von schlechtem Journalismus, von, ist das Daily Mail? Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, irgendein anderes britisches Medium, was halt keine besonders hohen Journalisten-Standards hat, finanziert den Guardian quer und selbst das reicht nicht aus. Also die Knights-Stiftung, die da der Träger ist vom Guardian, die sind auf dem besten Weg in die Pleite gerade. Das heißt also, da ist man ein bisschen im Dilemma, man sieht tolle Sachen und sieht auf der anderen Seite, dass es wirtschaftlich nicht funktioniert. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch die Huffington Post zum Beispiel, die das Ganze so betreibt, dass sie eben unglaublich viel Content auf ihrer Seite zulässt, auch von Laien, also Blogger, prominente Blogger und nicht prominente Blogger, User, die mitmachen. Und ja, das Geschäftsmodell ist natürlich auch von vielen kritisiert, weil die Laien-Blogger bekommen eben gar kein Geld bei Huffington Post.
Lass mal kurz ein bisschen weiter ausholen, was die Huffington Post betrifft, weil das war ja so ein Projekt, ich habe es nicht sehr aktiv begleitet, aber wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, also der Name kommt ja von der Arianna Huffington, genau, die hat das mal losgetreten und wenn ich mich richtig entsinne, war das am Anfang im Wesentlichen eine Initiative überhaupt, Blogs zu publizieren.
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht, wie das angefangen hat, ich glaube der Anspruch war von vornherein schon so eine Art Tageszeitung, was ja auch so ein bisschen im Namen zum Ausdruck kommt, Tageszeitung auf Grundlage von Blogbeiträgen zu...
Genau, so habe ich das auch wahrgenommen, aber dass man sozusagen explizit auf die Blogs zugegangen ist und dass ihr wisst, ihr wisst eh Bescheid, ihr habt da sozusagen eure Themen, ihr seid auch, sagen wir mal, euch muss man nicht zwingen, irgendwas digital zu veröffentlichen, das ist für euch eh normal, wir bieten euch einen Portal. Wobei sie nicht unbedingt gleich auch Geld geboten haben.
Genau, also das hat sich schon oder bricht sich heute immer noch an Blogger, die sowieso aktiv bloggen und die sich dann über diese Plattform nochmal mehr Leser holen können und generell für sich werben und ihr Blog werben können, klar. Also es ist sozusagen der Austausch, Aufmerksamkeit gegen Artikel, aber eben kein Geld. Also die Blogger bekommen, also ich weiß nicht, die Prominenten bekommen wahrscheinlich Geld, weiß ich nicht genau, aber nehme ich an, aber halt all die namenlosen, die Masse der Blogger bekommt da eben gar kein Geld. Und es gibt einen festen Redaktionsteam, die dann auch normal bezahlt werden, in Deutschland, wo die Hafting-Post gerade startet, sollen das glaube ich so 20 sein, die dann selber schreiben und teilweise eben auch mit den Bloggern kommunizieren. Und das ist, ja das wird von den Verlagen teilweise sehr stark angegriffen, das Modell. Also der Matthias Döpfner, der Axel Springer-Chef, hat sich jetzt in letzter Zeit häufiger sehr negativ über dieses Geschäftsmodell geäußert. Und ich selber bin so ein bisschen zugespalten, ich weiß nicht genau, ich finde den Ansatz interessant und es funktioniert ja anscheinend auch. Aber es ist wirklich die Frage, ob das ethisch so gut ist, wenn dann eben Journalismus so ein bisschen weiter in Richtung Hobby getrieben wird, was bei der Huff & Post eben der Fall ist. Also die allermeisten, die da schreiben und veröffentlichen, die machen das eben als Hobby und haben andere Einnahmenquellen und nicht den Journalismus.
Die Frage ist, hat das Medium als solches überhaupt Relevanz sich erarbeiten können? Weil ich meine, in dem Moment, wo es nicht ernst genommen wird, kann es ja nicht funktionieren als Journalismus.
Ja, die Huff & Post hat auf jeden Fall Relevanz in den USA und auch gewissermaßen in Großbritannien, wo sie auch schon aktiv ist. In Italien weiß ich nicht genau, aber da ist sie, glaube ich, auch aktiv, aber das weiß ich nicht. Da kenne ich es mal.
Ist nicht auch für Deutschland was geplant jetzt?
Jaja, genau. Die Huff & Post suchen momentan Redakteure. Die machen das hier zusammen mit Hubert Burda oder Burda Media Group, oder wie die auch immer heißen. Ist natürlich ein Verlag, der jetzt in Deutschland nicht unbedingt für hochklassige journalistische Formate bekannt ist, also ich glaube, der Fokus ist so das einzige echte journalistische Format, was da im Portfolio ist, ansonsten geht es ja eher Richtung Bund oder was, ich weiß nicht genau, was dazu gehört und das sehe ich auch nicht so sehr, aber...
Das sind dann wahrscheinlich wieder die Sachen, die das gut querfinanzieren können.
Ja, ja, aber möglicherweise könnte Huff and Thoes dann auch ein bisschen in die Richtung gehen, also dass dann viele Promi-Blogger da unterwegs sind oder so, also Boris Becker und Co., weiß ich nicht.
Ja, wobei ja der Border ja schon seit längerem auffällt durch diese Umtriebigkeit im digitalen Raum.
Stimmt, DLD.
Genau, mit dieser DLD-Konferenz, die läuft schon seit, ich weiß nicht, fünf oder sechs Jahren, wo es auch so einen interessanten Link danach Israel gibt und viel austauscht und wo dann ja mit dieser DLD-Konferenz auch geschickt, dass so platziert wurde, dass so die ganzen internationalen Prominenten dann immer auf dem Weg nach...
Von, nach Genf, ja.
Nicht nach Genf, sondern wie heißt...
Jaja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Das World Economic Forum.
Genau, da wo die ganzen Reichen sich mit den ganzen anderen Leuten unterhalten. Und das ist halt genau so getimed. Und ich glaube, da kommen solche Beziehungen her.
Ja, das ist...
Da wo es treffen sich.
Da wo es, genau. Nicht Genf.
Da kann man dann auch nur viel fahren. Ich war doch nicht da.
Also ich war bei der DLD und das war tatsächlich so, dass ganz viele auf der Durchreise waren. Also die haben die DLD mitgenommen.
Exakt. Das funktioniert ganz gut. Daher bin ich jetzt nicht so überrascht, dass sie da andocken. Die Frage ist natürlich, was bringt es den Bloggern und was bringt es halt dem Journalismus an der Stelle? Also denkst du das wirklich so, also ich höre schon raus, du bist da skeptisch, aber ist es nicht durchaus auch vorstellbar, dass eben so dieser Übergang von Hobby, Schreiben aus Interesse hin zu primär, Schreiben wollen über alles Mögliche, um damit ein Leben zu finanzieren, dass es da einfach so einen sanften Übergang geben kann, wo einfach viele Modelle Platz haben?
Das stimmt natürlich, ja, also das finde ich auch wirklich ein sehr, sehr positiver Aspekt der ganzen digitalen Revolution. Wenn du jemand bist, der was kann, wenn du eine interessante Geschichte hast, wenn du was recherchierst hast, dann brauchst du eben kein Video mehr, sondern du kannst es online stellen und wenn es wirklich was Interessantes ist, dann wird es sich wahrscheinlich auch verbreiten und die Huff & Post wäre natürlich dann ein weiterer Schritt, dass dieser Übergang schneller funktioniert, dass man eben schneller…
So für einen Beitrag einfach mal damit hineinkuratiert wird, weil es halt relevant ist. Das heißt, der Redakteur sucht sich im Prinzip, man könnte ja auch positiv sagen, es gibt halt eine Redaktion. Redaktion bedeutet ja im Kern, wir suchen die richtigen Themen zusammen, um sie in unserer Publikation zusammenzufassen und normalerweise bedient man sich halt nur des eigenen Personals und hier ist das Personal im Prinzip das ganze Netz.
Ja, im Grunde kann man ja sagen, das Internet ist generell, auch in anderen Branchen gibt es ja diese Vermischungen schon, dass man das Internet als Arbeitsmarkt betrachtet. Also es gibt ja beispielsweise ODesk, ist so ein Online-Vermittler von Arbeitskäften, wo dann viele sich auch Programmierer, je nach Bedarf gerade aus der ganzen Welt holen und auch virtuelle Teams machen und so was. Also das ist, glaube ich, generell so ein Trend des Internets, dass einfach alles flexibel wird in der Arbeitswelt.
Ja, wobei natürlich dann zusammen mit solchen Systemen wie Mechanical Turk, das natürlich dann auch alles so unter Sklaverei-Verdacht steht.
Ja, Mechanical Turk, da sind natürlich dann Aufgaben, die auch extrem primitive sind und die auch sehr, sehr schlecht bezahlt werden. ODesk ist da ein bisschen was anderes, weil da geht es eher um kölnisch verzierte Arbeit, also da geht es um Programmieraufgaben und so was.
Ja gut, aber auch an der Stelle entscheidet natürlich am Ende der Preis und umso größer das Einzugsgebiet.
Das stimmt, klar. Also die Programmierer aus Bangladesh drücken natürlich die Preise für die Programmierer in Deutschland.
Das ist klar. Das könnte ich mir nämlich auch gut vorstellen. Ja, bleiben wir nochmal so bei den anderen Modellen. Also da ist jetzt Guardian genannt, Guardian ist so ein bisschen der heilige Gral, eben weil, wie du schon gesagt hast, da einfach so viel investiert wurde. Ich glaube, und wenn ich es auch richtig verstanden habe, das ist glaube ich auch so ein Schritt, den viele eben noch nicht so richtig bereit sind zu machen. Es gibt keinen Unterschied, korrigiere mich, wenn ich das jetzt falsch mitgenommen habe, aber das war so meine Darstellung. Im Prinzip ist es so reorganisiert worden, dass es jetzt zwischen Online und Print in dem Sinne keine klare Trennung mehr gibt.
Genau, der Guardian hat schon, ich weiß gar nicht seit wann, ich glaube schon Mitte der Nullerjahre die integrierte Redaktion eingeführt. Das ist eigentlich auch ein Schlagwort, was schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren in den Redaktionen herumgeistert und was immer wieder gefordert wird. Und der Guardian hat es einfach gemacht, also so weit ich weiß, ich war noch nicht in Reaktionsräumen, ich habe mir das noch nicht selber angeguckt, aber soweit ich das gelesen habe, ist es tatsächlich so, dass da keine Trennung gemacht wird zwischen Online und Print und dass eben alle für alle Plattformen arbeiten und eben auch zusammenarbeiten und jeder macht eben sein Thema für alle Kanäle.
Das hältst du auch für sinnvoll?
Ja, ich glaube im Prinzip schon, es kommt ein bisschen auf die Reaktionsgröße wahrscheinlich auch an, also der Garten ist einfach sehr, sehr gut ausgestattet mit Personal, grundsätzlich halte ich das schon für richtig auf jeden Fall. Also ich meine, es ist ja schon absurd, dass im interne Zeitalter in vielen Redaktionen Redakteure nach Redaktionsschluss arbeiten und dann irgendwie den Griff fallen lassen, sobald irgendwie die Zeitung im Print ist und dann ist die Arbeit getan. Also wir leben in einer Welt, die sich jederzeit verändert und demischerweise muss der Journalismus das ja als Welterklärer auch abbilden, auch in der eigenen Arbeitsweise. Also ich glaube schon, dass...
Du willst aber wahrscheinlich trotzdem auch mal deinen Nachmittag im Garten verbringen.
Ja, das schon natürlich.
Das würde in der Auszeit nehmen, wie so viel er anbaut.
Dafür muss man eben, dass ich sage, Personal ist dann eben das Stichwort. Also wenn eine Redaktion mit genug Personal ausgestattet ist, dann halt jetzt für den richtigen Weg. Wenn nicht, dann muss man halt sich den Gegebenheiten dann entsprechend anpassen.
Das heißt, so eine redaktionelle Trennung auf Basis des Veröffentlichungskanals, in dem Sinne, erhältst du für ein Auslaufmodell?
Es ist auf jeden Fall in vielen Redaktionen derzeit ein Auslaufmodell. Es wird überall versucht, also fast überall zumindest, wo ich jetzt Kontakteinhaber, dass alles verbinden, die Plattformen. Es gibt natürlich da viele Hürden, das fängt an mit der Technik.
Also, dass du jetzt sagst, viele, das finde ich bemerkenswert, weil meine Wahrnehmung ist eigentlich so ein bisschen anders. Also, wenn man jetzt schaut beim Spiegel, gibt es eine ganz klare Trennung zwischen Spiegel und Spiegel Online?
Eine ganz klare Trennung, das liegt aber auch daran, dass der Spiegel als Printprodukt ein anderes Format, also ein ganz anderes Format, das ist eben ein Wochenmagazin und kein Nachrichten.
Okay, aber bei der Taz gibt es diese Unterscheidungen in ähnlicher Form. Also zumindest wird mit dem Printprodukt online ganz anders umgegangen. Also es ist nicht so, dass man da denselben Inhalt hätte.
Ja, also es gibt natürlich, klar, es gibt...
Also es handelt sich nicht um dasselbe tägliche Produkt, sondern es gibt halt Artikel, die nur online sind und die, die im Print sind, sind zwar irgendwie auch online, aber dann eben nur, damit Google das findet, wenn man danach sucht, aber bloß nicht jetzt in so einem Online-Verzeichnis, dass man das vielleicht auch selber finden könnte. Das ist schon so ein bisschen schizophren, finde ich manchmal und es bewirkt bei mir auch immer dieses Misstrauen gegenüber diesen Produkten, dass ich einfach auch, also erstmal ist es so, ich treffe was an im Print. Ich meine, Print hat ja auch seine Vorteile, das kann man irgendwie schön ausbreiten, da muss man gar nicht weiter diskutieren. Manche mögen es, manche mögen es nicht, aber manchmal funktioniert es halt einfach besser und hat natürlich auch von seiner Darstellung her eben ganz andere Qualitäten als so ein kleiner Bildschirm. Aber dann habe ich so einen Artikel und irgendwie sagt mir so ein Print-Artikel auch immer, wenn ich den jetzt zitieren möchte, dann wird das nicht gehen, weil der dann aus irgendwelchen bekloppten Gründen nicht im Netz ist.
Das stört mich auch immer wieder.
Das stuft für mich dann immer diesen Artikel ab. Ich bin dann immer wieder überrascht, wenn der dann doch drin ist, weil es halt dann irgendwie noch so eine Selektion gibt mit naja, was könnten wir denn jetzt hier so einzeln online machen und so weiter und es ist auch unklar, wann der erscheint, sind die zeitgleich, kommt das irgendwie einen Tag später, eine Woche später, ist das dann nur im Archiv, muss man dafür bezahlen, das ist ein großes Drama.
Ja, das stimmt. Also das muss ich auch sagen, ich kaufe mir auch ab und zu nochmal Printprodukte, zum Beispiel die Frankfurter Allgemeine Sonntagszeitung, da wo ich im Fitnessstudio bin am Wochenende und wo ich in die Sauna gehe dann umsonst und dann kann ich es mir in Ruhe angucken und es stirbt mich auch jedes Mal wieder, wenn ich einen Artikel finde und denke, jetzt müsste ich eigentlich hier Freunden zeigen, die ihn auch interessieren und so weiter und dann ist er halt nicht online und das ist wirklich eine Abwertung des ganzen Produkts dann auf jeden Fall.
Wie würdest du das lösen, wenn du jetzt so, ist eine gute Frage, ein kleiner QR-Code mit der URL ans Ende?
Ich glaube, um nochmal ganz kurz ein bisschen auszuholen, es gibt ja so zwei Arten von Lesern, die man online eigentlich bedient, also wenn man es mal ganz grob aufteilt, es gibt den einen, den News-Junkie, der auf die Seite geht und immer wieder die neuesten News haben will und schon die ganze Zeit mit dem Finger auf R5 ist und guckt, was Neues kommt und es gibt den, der ein-, zweimal am Tag auf die Seite kommt und sich über das Wichtigste informieren will. Und das sind, also für beide Leser muss man die Seite ganz anders aufbauen und der letztgenannte User ist ja eigentlich auch der User, der ein Printprodukt kauft, der will das Wichtigste oben haben, sich einen Überblick verschaffen über die wichtigsten Themen und das wird online momentan noch nicht abgebildet, dieser Use-Case. Es gibt keine Ansicht online, wenn ich auf Spiegel online gehe, dann weiß ich, ganz oben ist jeden Tag ein Artikel zu jeder Zeit, also außer jetzt nachts, der in den letzten Stunden irgendwie aktualisiert wurde und selbst wenn es nicht das Wichtigste ist, ist es ja trotzdem gerade oben, weil einfach das gerade neu reingekommen ist.
Auf jeden Fall, es ändert sich alle 30 Minuten.
Ja, es wird immer wieder gedreht, wie man das nennt, im Journalismus, im Online-Journalismus. Man versucht die Taktung irgendwie hochzuhalten, immer wieder eben Leute zu bringen, neu auf ein Artikel zu klicken. Und ich würde sagen, man bräuchte eigentlich diese zwei Ansichten, also man bräuchte eigentlich zwei Reiter, dass man sagt, das eine ist das Online-Live-Angebot, wo jetzt wirklich das aktuell Neue oben steht und das andere ist das, wo ich mir einfach den Überblick verschaffe. Und das zweite Angebot, das könnte eigentlich auch ziemlich nah am Print sein. Es müsste dann vielleicht so dreimal am Tag aktualisiert werden, aber dann sollte eben da auch wirklich das Wichtigste stehen und sollte auch da dann alles stehen, was man im Print hat. Aber diese Trennung gibt es jetzt, glaube ich, noch nirgendwo in keinem journalistischen Format. Würde mir zumindest gerade nichts einfallen.
Es gibt so grobe Unterscheidungen, so mit Tickern und so, wo dann immer das Neueste oben nacheinander, das aufgelistet ist, wie man das bei Heise ja schon seit Jahr und Tag findet. Und dann gibt es nochmal so Übersichtseiten, die schon auch bestimmte Artikel mehr in den Vordergrund rücken. Das wäre jetzt das einzige Beispiel, was mir jetzt auch so auffällt. Das mit der Taktung ist sehr interessant, weil das Netz ja im Prinzip mit dem Stunden oder überhaupt nur mit dem halbtagestack da überhaupt erstmal was ganz Neues eingeführt hat, was ja so mit Print gar nicht machbar gewesen ist. Das war so das Maximum, was man eigentlich an Aktualisierungen erfahren konnte und damit hat man sich dann irgendwie auch gewöhnt. Und es ist halt auch die Frage, ob man wirklich so sehr viel mehr auch wirklich benötigt. Aber das stellen wir mal hinten an. Zusätzlich gab es ja dann noch die Wochenblätter, Magazine, Wochenzeitungen und natürlich auch die monatlichen Postillen oder halbmonatlichen Produktionen, die es ja auch gibt, die auch nach wie vor existieren und die auch in irgendeiner Form versuchen, im Netz präsent zu sein. Was davon denkst du denn, kann denn vom Netz am meisten profitieren?
Ja, man kann doch umgekehrt fragen, was davon ist am gefährdetsten durch das Netz. Aber ich würde sagen, dass das Wochenmagazin immer noch ganz gut im Print funktioniert. Man kann sehen, die Zeit und die Frankfurter Allgemeine Sonntagszeitung feiern Auflagenrekorde, wirtschaftlich geht es denen extrem gut, obwohl die Zeit alles online stellt. Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Artikel, der nicht online zu finden ist, weil das ein Leanback-Medium ist, wo man am Wochenende eben Zeit hat, sich das wirklich ausbreitet, wie du gesagt hast, und dann so richtig schön schmökert. Das funktioniert eben auch immer noch im Print.
Und es gibt eine URL für jeden Artikel quasi, auch wenn sie da nicht direkt abgedruckt werden.
Genau, also wenn man googelt, findet man jeden Artikel. Zumindest habe ich bisher jeden Artikel gefunden, bei der Zeit jetzt, bei der RWS nicht. Die wochenmagazine und die halbmonatliche magazine, die, glaube ich, wenn die jetzt das 1 zu 1 einfach nur im freien Web abbilden würden, würden sie davon wahrscheinlich nicht so profitieren. Das ist halt auch eine Art von Journalismus, die man jetzt nicht so gerne am PC-Modulator liest, sondern das will man dann, wie gesagt, entweder im Print wirklich immer noch haben oder dann auf einem Tablet, glaube ich.
Das heißt, an der Stelle müsste man eigentlich auch mal verschiedene Journalismus-Formen unterscheiden. Dieses News-Liefern, was halt die Tageszeitungen mit abgedeckt haben und dann gab es noch so ein paar reflektierte Meinungskommentare. Das steht natürlich am stärksten unter Bedrohung, weil auf einmal dieses Anliefern von Nachrichten und das Abdrucken von dpa und ähnlichen Agenturen, das kann man halt im Netz wunderbar automatisieren und funktioniert an der Stelle besser, weil es eben noch schneller ist. Während die Wochenmagazine ja eigentlich auch eine ganz andere Form des Journalismus darstellen, weil man eben sehr viel mehr analytisch, also mehr eigentlich in diese Geschichtenform reingeht, von der du am Anfang gesprochen hast.
Ja, wobei ich würde sagen, ein guter Agenturtext, der Nachrichtstransmitter ist auch immer ein bisschen aufgebaut wie eine Geschichte oder erzählt einem eine Geschichte, aber klar, diese Einordnungsfunktion, das ist eben das, was immer noch viel nachgefragt wird, wo es immer noch einen Mangel im Netz gibt. Also was es im Netz im Überfluss gibt, sind eben Nachrichten, News, das, was Agenturen liefern, das hat eben jeder überall, in allen Sprachen und auf allen möglichen Websites. Und die Analyse, der Kommentar, die Einordnung, das ist eben das, was eher das knappe Gut ist und wofür Leute jetzt noch bereit sind, zu zahlen. Und die Tageszeitungen gehen ja auch ein bisschen in die Richtung, dass sie versuchen, weniger Nachrichten zu bringen, die am Vortag im Netz eh schon standen, alle gelesen haben auf Spiegel Online, sondern eben dann versuchen, ja, man sagt das im Journalisten-Sprech, den Weiterdreh zu bringen. Das heißt also, zu versuchen, was heißt die Nachricht, wie können wir weiterdenken, wie kann es weitergehen, wir gehen über die Nachricht hinaus, fragen Leute an, die es einordnen und so weiter. Weiterdreh, ja. Ja, Journalisten haben viele seltsame Worte, die sie benutzen. Aber da sind ja... Das muss ja alle sagen. Aber sie nörts ja auch nicht anders.
Ja, ich mach mir beim Podcasting auch häufig Gedanken über den Weiterdreh.
Ja, genau, also am schwersten haben es natürlich dann alle die, die wirklich die Nachricht bringen. Und das Problem ist auch ein bisschen an der Stelle, dass wenn jetzt jemand wirklich investiert in Recherche und eine Nachricht auf den Markt bringt, sobald die auf dem Markt ist, hat die halt jeder sofort. Und das muss auch so sein, dass es auch wichtig ist, weil sonst würden wir die Informationsfreiheit einschränken und das wäre das Schlechteste für einen Journalismus. Aber es heißt natürlich trotzdem, dass es sich nicht unbedingt lohnt, der Erste zu sein bei einer Nachricht. Und dass da die Anreizstruktur nicht unbedingt so ist, dass man jetzt die neue Nachricht unbedingt bringen muss, sondern dass die Anreizstruktur eher so ist, dass man versucht, sich auf andere Felder zu konzentrieren, die auch nicht so aufwendig sind.
Mehr Wert zu schaffen. Vielleicht, bevor wir mal den Bereich verlassen, ich würde noch mal ein paar Beispiele interessieren, wie jetzt andere mit online umgehen. Du hast ja vorhin auch den New York Times genannt, die sehr erfolgreich sei im Netz.
Die New York Times ist im Netz zumindest so erfolgreich, dass jetzt die Umsätze durch Abonnements online die der Werbeumsätze übertreffen, was viele Jahre lang nicht der Fall war. Die New York Times, da geht es aber wirtschaftlich immer noch nicht gut. Also die schreibt immer noch Verluste. Auch zum Beispiel für sehr guten Journalismus, der auf der ganzen Welt gelobt wird und Auszeichnung bekommt und wirtschaftlich nicht erfolgreich ist. Wirtschaftlich erfolgreich ist das Wall Street Journal tatsächlich. Natürlich durch das Internet. Man muss auch dazu vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz sagen, also New York Times und Wall Street Journal als die beiden großen US-Medien konnten natürlich vom Internet auch noch viel mehr profitieren als jetzt beispielsweise ein deutsches Medium, ein deutschsprachiges Medium, weil der potenzielle Leserkreis sich einfach mal vervielfacht hat. Also es gibt auf der ganzen Welt Manager, Wirtschaftsinteressierte, die englischsprachige Medien konsumieren können und sich dafür interessieren. Das heißt also, das Wall Street Journal aktuell online hat halt Leser auf der ganzen Welt und konnte da den Leserkreis, wie gesagt, ins Internet einfach potenzieren. Und das ist natürlich in dem Maße nicht der Fall für ein deutschsprachiges Medium.
Naja, aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch den deutschsprachigen Medien natürlich auch die Gelegenheit, in derselben Sprache mit zu spielen, also Spiegel, zum Beispiel gibt es ja auch in einer internationalen Fassung, auch wenn das sicherlich jetzt nicht so relevant ist.
Also das ist, glaube ich, ein Verlustgeschäft für den Spiegel. Also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich großartig wahrgenommen wird. Weil also gerade in der englischsprachigen Welt hat man natürlich auch einfach die riesige Auswahl nochmal an Medien, also nochmal auch was da an Blogs noch in den USA.
Na klar, aber ich denke an der Stelle muss der Wert natürlich auch so ein bisschen in der Markenbedeutung gebessen werden und in dem Moment, wo man sich ein internationales Portal gibt als deutsches Medium. Damit zeichnet man sich natürlich auch aus als, hallo hier, wir sind die Checker von Deutschland. Wenn ihr was wissen wollt, dann fragt doch uns. Das ist auch kein unerheblicher Anteil, aber das ist sicherlich jetzt nur neben Kriegsschauplatz. Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei der New York Times. Du meintest ja Abonnements. Was war das? Also sie machen mehr Geld mit Online-Abonnements als mit Online-Werbung.
Also es wäre beides online.
Das heißt, hier ist so das gemeinhin als Paywall verschriebene Konzept von es ist gar nicht alles frei online verfügbar.
Also die New York Times hat ja die sogenannte metered Paywall erfunden. Das ist auch ein Buzzword unter Verlagen. Alle eifern dann New York Times in der Hinsicht auch nach. Also unter um die Welt hat die jetzt gerade eingeführt. Metered Paywall bedeutet, wir machen jetzt keine komplette Schranke vor unser Angebot, sondern wir machen so ein abgestufte Schranke. Das heißt also bei New York Times ist das so gelöst, dass Google-Treffer, Traffic über soziale Netzwerke wie Twitter und Facebook immer komplett frei sind und niemals auf das Kontingent sozusagen zählen der Freiklicks. Also man hat glaube ich pro Monat irgendwie als User mit einer IP 20 Freiklicks oder sowas, wenn man auf die Seite geht. Also nach 20 Mal Artikel-Aufrufe wird man halt aufgefordert, die Paywall zu bezahlen und kann keine weiteren mehr aufrufen. Aber wenn man über Google kommt oder über Twitter oder über Facebook oder über...
Irgendein soziales Medium sozusagen.
Ja, ich glaube auch Blogs gehen auch dazu. Dann wird das nicht gezählt, dann kommt man trotzdem drauf. Und der Ansatz ist sozusagen, wir maximieren einerseits diesen Zufall-Traffic, der auf unsere Seite kommt durch soziale Medien, durch die Verbreitung im Netz und andererseits bitten wir aber die regelmäßigen Leser trotzdem zur Kasse.
Das heißt, die Leute, die sozusagen auch schon die Website als Portal zu Nachrichten verstehen und da primär los suchen und nicht zufällig auf irgendwas stoßen wollen, sondern sagen, okay, ich weiß, das hat für mich einen gewissen Wert, dass ich da als erstes hingehe. Die werden dann auch anders behandelt.
Genau, die werden bestraft.
Na ja, gut, das ist die Frage, weil sie fangen überhaupt erst mal an, das Medium als solches zu nutzen.
Genau, sie nutzen das als Einstieg. Genau, als Einstieg.
Ihr Portal.
Genau, sie haben auch wahrscheinlich eine andere Verbindung dazu, also eine andere Nähe und sind vermutlich auch eher bereit, dann eben dafür zu zahlen.
Ja, weil sie den Wert schon entdeckt haben. Ich meine, das ist auch etwas, was ich immer wieder finde, jetzt auch so in der, ich will jetzt nicht Netzgemeinde sagen, aber sagen wir mal in dieser digitalen Öffentlichkeit. Da gibt es so eine merkwürdige Schizophrenie, was das Verhältnis zu den journalistischen Organisationen betrifft. Weil auf der einen Seite fordert man die ganze Zeit, ja, ich will hier alles recherchieren, auf alles zugreifen können, ja, wo ist denn hier die URL etc. Ja, auf der anderen Seite, ohne dann dafür bezahlen zu wollen, das heißt in dem Moment Payfall ist das allererste Mal Aufgaben, da war ja sozusagen der Shitstorm schon maximal, ja, das hat sich glaube ich so ein bisschen gelegt. Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Es gibt auch ein paar Gegner, so Jeff Jarvis ist immer noch so ein großer Gegner, aber ja.
Ja gut, aber da sehe ich sozusagen auch keinen klaren Trend, darauf wollte ich nämlich eigentlich gerade hinaus, und dann auf der anderen Seite in dem Moment, wo die Werbung allzu sehr in den Vordergrund rückt, weil sie ja in der Lage ist, einen freien Zugang zu refinanzieren, zumindest theoretisch, ist das eben dann auch wieder bekloppt. Und so wie jetzt gerade vor kurzem, ein, zwei Wochen, bevor wir hier die Sendung aufgezeichnet haben, gab es so eine etwas skurrile Aktion, an der Spiegel und noch ein paar andere...
Spiegel, süddeutsche.de, golem.de, RP Online, ja, da waren es so ein paar.
Genau, also so verschiedene Organisationen teilgenommen haben, die ja sagen so, ja, wir wollen ja hier den Qualitätsjournalismus, weiß man ganz genau, wie es vorhin formuliert war, aber wir würden das halt gerne alles hier frei für euch anbieten, aber ihr verwendet ja alle böse Adblocker, schaltet die doch mal bitte ab für uns, weil wir so lieb sind. Und da gab es dann auch gleich wieder den Shitstorm. Also man kann es irgendwie sozusagen niemandem recht machen, habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, auf der einen Seite bezahlen, auf der anderen Seite indirekt bezahlen auch nicht. Also das eine nervt und das andere nervt auch. Da frage ich mich so ein bisschen, was so der goldene Weg ist. Dann gab es dann so eine zweite Eskalationsstufe, in der die Leute dann zum Besten gegeben haben, dass sie ja eigentlich durchaus bereit wären zu zahlen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch etwas, was man generell langsam sieht im Internet. Am Anfang war alles noch so experimentell und alles so unklar, dass die Bereitschaft, an der Stelle das ganze Netz auch wirklich so als Primärmedium zu akzeptieren und an der Stelle auch diese finanziellen Transaktionen anzustoßen, die so in der normalen, normalen jetzt komme ich auch schon mit dieser merkwürdigen Unterscheidung, aber die sagen, wenn ich jetzt eine Zeitung kaufe oder so weiter, dann gebe ich auch sofort Geld aus. Das hat ja nun über Jahrzehnte funktioniert, aber der selbe Mechanismus war jetzt im Netz nicht so automatisch. Zumal es ja eben auch nicht so dieses Äquivalent so Bargeld gibt. Ich denke, ein großes Problem an der Stelle ist halt Payment als solches. Aber dann kamen eben so diese Modelle hoch mit, ich würde ja gerne was zahlen, aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ein Interesse daran, mit jeder einzelnen Zeitung irgendwie ein Abo-Modell einzugeben. Also bei der New York Times mag das ja an der Stelle funktionieren. Also in dem Moment, wo man sozusagen das akzeptierte, beste oder verbreitetste Medium ist. Ich denke, Spiegel hätte ähnliche Chancen, theoretisch zumindest, zu sagen, na ja, wir machen jetzt vielleicht hier auch diese Mieter-Paywall. Ihr klickt hier viel rum. Viele Leute benutzen ja sozusagen auch Spiegel als ihre Startseite. Spiegel versucht das auch ja geradezu aufzuzwängen, die Homepage zu werden, sodass man sich das eben ganz gut vorstellen könnte. Aber was ist dann eben mit den anderen? Dann habe ich hier ein Bezahlmodell, da ein Bezahlmodell und dann habe ich wieder dieses Problem mit 30.000 Abos.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Riesenproblem. Also diese wenig flexiblen Bezahlmodelle sehe ich auch als ganz entscheidend dafür, warum das einfach nicht funktioniert. Es gibt ja momentan wirklich nur die Möglichkeit bei denen, also es gibt ja generell in Deutschland relativ wenige, die Bezahlmodelle anbieten, aber wenn, dann ist es immer so, du musst ein Abo abschließen, du zahlst nicht irgendwie ein Artikel für wenig Geld, sondern wenn es das gibt, dieses Angebot, einen Artikel zu bezahlen, dann ist der meistens, also bei der FAZ ist das zum Beispiel der Fall, dann ist der einfach absurd teuer. Also dann kostet irgendwie ein Artikel so viel wie die ganze Ausgabe normalerweise in der Zeitung, das funktioniert natürlich auch nicht. Also da glaube ich auf jeden Fall muss mehr Flexibilität hin reinkommen, das ganze Modell und man kann sich auch mal darüber Gedanken machen, ob es vielleicht auch irgendwie so eine Art von, ja, medienübergreifenden Abo oder sowas lohnen würde. Also da muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein mit Kartellrecht und so, aber dass man Verlage sich zusammenschließt und sagen, wir machen bestimmte Artikel einfach in einer Paywall und wenn du, also wir haben einmal, die geben einmal die Möglichkeit, den Einzelnen zu bezahlen für wenig Geld oder du schließt ein Abo ab und kommst dann auf alle Artikel von allen Medien. Ich habe jetzt kürzlich mit jemandem gesprochen, der ist 18, ich bin ja selber 30, also habe nicht mehr so viel zu tun mit 18-jährigen, aber der sagt ja auch irgendwie, ich surfe jeden Tag zehn Websiten an, also zehn Nachrichten-Webseiten, ich zahle jetzt auch nicht, also ich bin bereit zu zahlen, sagt er ja auch, aber ich zahle auch nicht für eine, sondern wenn, dann muss es doch wirklich dann, dass ich auf alle zehn zugreifen kann. Wir sind halt so aufgewachsen, also meine Generation und gerade die, die nach mir kommen, dass man einfach dieses Angebot hat von all den Nachrichten-Webseiten, man ist nicht mehr auf einer Website, sondern man nutzt halt, weiß nicht, zwischen fünf und zehn wahrscheinlich jeden Tag für verschiedene Zwecke und da muss es eigentlich Modelle geben, dass man auch einfach für alles bezahlen kann und nicht jedes Abo einschließen muss, das glaube ich auf jeden Fall auch.
Und das siehst du auch so als das wünschenswerte Ziel an?
Es ist ein Weg, also ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich muss zweigleisig fahren. Also einerseits, dass man wirklich für wenig Geld einzelne Artikel kaufen kann, vielleicht auch zum Beispiel als ein Autor, das ist auch möglich, dass man sagt, dieser Autor, der schreibt immer so coole Sachen, von dem will ich eigentlich alles lesen, dann schließe ich ein Abo für diesen Autor ab, das ist auch möglich oder vielleicht auch, dass man noch ein bisschen was dazu bekommt. Also, da gibt es auch ganz interessante Experimente in den USA.
Oder auch nur einen bestimmten Themenbereich.
Ja, zum Beispiel, genau.
Ja, mich interessiert nur Wirtschaft oder mich interessiert nur, keine Ahnung.
Ja. Also, es gibt zum Beispiel die Texas Tribune in den USA, so eine Lokalzeitung. Wenn man da ein Abo abschließt, dann bekommt man zum Beispiel auch solche Sachen, wie dass man zu Veranstaltungen eingeladen wird und dann da mit Experten reden darf. Und es ist auch ein kleiner Kreis dann eben von 30 Leuten oder so, dass jeder mal zu Wort kommt. Also, es ist da viel möglich. Noch irgendwie umzusetzen mit Bezahlmodellen. Es muss nicht immer Inhalt gegen Geld sein, sondern es kann halt auch mehr sein. Man könnte sich vorstellen, dass man mit einzelnen Journalisten reden kann oder so was, weil die sich in irgendeinem Gebiet auskennen und man da Hilfe braucht oder so was. Es gibt da wirklich viele Möglichkeiten und da wurde bisher wirklich sehr wenig ausprobiert.
Eine ganze Menge wurde ja eigentlich schon ausprobiert im Bereich der Erfassung der Lesenden. Also primär dann wahrscheinlich auch eben für die Werbung bzw. für die Steigerung der Werbepreise, die man nehmen kann. Dazu muss man natürlich bemessen werden, sozusagen die Popularität muss nachgewiesen werden. Das führte dann eben schnell zu dieser ganzen Zentralisierung der Werbeeinblendungsdienste, sodass eben viele Webseiten dieselben Dienste benutzen. Dadurch wurden diese Dienste auf einmal besser erkennbar. Das führte dann wiederum zu diesen Adblockern, die dann einfach gesagt haben, okay, wenn das alles so einfach zu erkennen ist, dann blenden wir das auch einfach wieder aus. Beiß sich die Katze wieder so ein bisschen den Schwanz. Was mich mal kurz nochmal interessieren würde, wäre, was denn eigentlich so diese gängigen Zählmethoden sind. Also, was sind diese internen Währungseinheiten, in denen Online-Journalismus bemisst oder versucht, messbar zu werden. Weil das hat ja dann auch mal relativ große Auswirkungen auf die Art und Weise, wie der Content angeboten wird.
Genau, es gibt erst mal zwei Organisationen, die in Deutschland da relevant sind. Das ist IVW und AGOF. Die sind die Organisationen, die diese Klicks messen. Da gibt es eben zwei verschiedene Arten von Klicks, die gemessen werden. Einmal die Wizards, das sind die IP-Adressen, die auf die Seite kommen. Das heißt nicht immer, dass es ein Mensch ist. Es können auch mehrere Menschen sein, es können auch zwei IP-Adressen ein Mensch sein. Das ist nicht so ganz sauber, aber auf jeden Fall werden die Wizards von IP-Adressen gemessen. Und das andere sind die Impressions, das heißt einfach die Aufrufe von Seiten. Und die letztere Währung, also die Impressions, die haben zu schlimmen Verwerfungen geführt im Online-Journalismus. Ich glaube, die allermeisten sind inzwischen mit so was wie Klickstrecken vertraut und auch mit den Exzessen, die damit verbunden sind, dass man in jedes Thema in einer Klickstrecke abfährt oder eben vollkommen unsinnige Klickstrecken baut. Also mein persönliches Favorite-Beispiel ist da immer noch Welt. Die haben nämlich mal 333 Fakten über Sex gebracht. Also das ist wirklich eine komplett absurde Klickstrecke.
Die dann auch sozusagen 333 Klicks erforderte.
Genau, und man muss 333 mal klicken, um sie komplett durchzulesen.
So, und es geht gar nicht darum, die Effektivität von irgendwas zu steigern?
Genau, es geht nicht um den Leser.
Es geht nur darum, dass eine Page-Impression gezählt wird, damit diese Zahl hochgeht, damit der Gesamtattraktivität für den Werbemarkt steigt, obwohl eigentlich nichts getan würde, um Werbung wirklich besser zu transformieren. Also man taucht wahrscheinlich immer wieder eine andere Werbung auf oder vielleicht auch dieselbe.
Die Werbung wird einfach neu geladen.
Aber es ändert sich jetzt eigentlich für den User in dem Sinne gar nichts, außer dass er mehr Arbeit damit hat.
Genau, es nervt den User eigentlich nur. Klickstecken können ihren Sinn haben, wenn es um die Bilder geht. Es gibt durchaus journalistische Erzählformen, wo eine Klickstrecke sinnvoll ist. Ich weiß, das ist gar nicht grundsätzlich verdammt, aber die Exzesse in diese Richtung, dass eben alles oder ganz viel zu einer Klickstrecke gemacht wurde, auch Sachen, die sich nicht geeignet haben.
Oder überhaupt Artikel in mehrere Teile aufzuteilen ohne Not.
Genau, das ist auch eine Folge davon. Wobei man dazu sagen muss, diese Impressions haben zum Glück an Wichtigkeit verloren, an Bedeutung verloren. Es zählen jetzt mehr die Visits aktuell für die Werbeindustrie.
Also Visit ist dann sozusagen, jemand kommt auf die Seite, verbleibt über mehrere Seiten dort und...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das ein Konfirm ist. Ja, ich glaube, genau, so Zufallsklicks, wo man per Google ganz kurz raufkommt und wieder weg ist, dann wird es, glaube ich, nicht gezählt. Und ansonsten wird es gezählt. Das sind einfach die Leser, die Leserreichweite eigentlich.
AGOF heißt Arbeitsgemeinschaft Online-Forschung. Und IVW. Also das sind sozusagen die beiden Informationsgemeinschafts zur Feststellung der Verbreitung von Werbeträgern.
Genau, bei der IVW sieht man schon, das kommt natürlich aus dem Printzeitalter, sieht man schon am sehr umständlichen Begriff. Die messen halt auch die Printauflage immer und die Leserreichweite. Und ich glaube, ein bisschen ist auch da. Also bei AGOF zum Beispiel, die haben die Impressions nie eine Rolle gespielt. Die haben immer nur die Versatz gemessen. Und ich glaube, diese ganze Fehlentwicklung durch Impressions ist auch ein bisschen auf die IVW zurückzuführen, was da halt Leute darüber entschieden haben, wie man online reich wird. Da müsst ihr von eigentlich keine Ahnung haben. Also es gibt da noch mehr Exzessen. Also es gab da noch so Doku-Spiele, die man auf der Seite spielen konnte, wo man dann durch jeden Klick die Seite auch nur aufgerufen hat und ähnliches. Also da kann man sich wirklich einiges ansehen, was da an Exzessen stattgefunden hat.
Ja, das Interessante ist eigentlich, man frustriert halt seine Leser. Und da stellt sich natürlich wieder so eine generelle Frage des Internets so, wer ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich sozusagen der Kunde? Also fühlt man sich hier eigentlich als Leser, als derjenige, dem eigentlich zugearbeitet wird, oder wird hier eigentlich im Wesentlichen der IVW und damit natürlich der Kunde?
Deswegen bin ich auch ein bisschen skeptisch über diese ganze Ideologie, alles muss offen sein. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich einerseits schön, wenn jeder auf alles Zugriff hat. Aber man muss sich einfach bewusst sein als Leser, wenn man auf alles kostenlos zugeführt ist, ist man eben nicht der Kunde, sondern das Produkt, wie man so schön sagt, dann ist nämlich die Werbeindustrie letztlich der Kunde. Und da wird nämlich nach der alles ausgerichtet. Weil die dann eben das Geld dafür zahlt. Und da muss man sich als Leser eben wirklich fragen, wo du auch wieder auf dieses Thema zurückkommst, was du eben angesprochen hast. Die Leute wollen einerseits keine Payrolls, andererseits auch nicht bezahlen. Wenn die Leser nicht bezahlen, sind sie einfach nicht der Kunde. Und das führt dann eben auch zu solchen Exzessen, dass sie nicht mehr im Mittelpunkt stehen. Steve Jobs hat auch mal gesagt, die Hardware-Hersteller, die sogenannten Smartphone-Hersteller vor dem iPhone, die haben immer nicht die Kunden im Blick gehabt, also die Nutzer, sondern die Mobilfunk-Provider.
Das waren diejenigen, die gekauft haben.
Genau. Und dann haben sie für die die Geräte designed. Und so waren sie dann auch. Und so sehe ich das auch ein bisschen im Journalismus. Wenn dann die Leute eben nicht selber zahlen, dann sind sie auch nicht diejenigen, die dann intakt vorgehen.
Aber eigentlich wäre das ja genau wünschenswert. Weil letzten Endes schreibt man ja für den Leser. Der Journalist tut das zumindest, auch wenn der Verlag dann sozusagen da ein anderes Modell drüber stirbt. Aber wenn man jetzt gut an einen Artikel rangeht, dann möchte man natürlich im Wesentlichen denken wir darüber, wie wird es aufgenommen. Und das heißt, die Wertschätzung dafür findet ja dann im Kopf des Lesers, Rezipienten. Wir lassen jetzt diese ganze Fernsehvideosache nochmal raus. Vielleicht kommen wir einfach am Schluss auch nochmal so ein bisschen drauf. Aber ich denke, dieser ganze Printbereich oder Schreiblesebereich ist auch irgendwie immer so ein bisschen das Auge des Sturms hier in dieser ganzen Debatte. Weil es da eben auch am schwierigsten ist. Auch weil sich das Netz eben extrem gut um Text kümmern kann. Im Guten wie im Schlechten. Worauf wollte ich hinaus? Also ich wollte noch mal so ein bisschen bei diesen möglichen Bezahlmodellen bleiben und was sich da abzeichnet. Also wir haben ja schon festgestellt, es gibt so eine gewisse Schwäche im Netz generell, einfach was das Bezahlen betrifft. In der Zeit ist Bezahlen schwierig, Bezahlen aus vielen Gründen. Einerseits wegen dieser ganzen Sicherheitsproblematiken. Aber auch weil wir ja letzten Endes da eigentlich auch noch verhältnismäßig alte Konzepte nutzen. So Kreditkarten und Banküberweisungen und so weiter. Alles sehr schwerfällige Prozesse. Und gerade das, was sich hier immer wieder herauszeichnet, so dieses partielle Konsumieren von Gesamtangebot. Es mag es eine riesige News-Site geben, aber mich interessiert einfach mal nur 0,001% dieser Inhalte und eigentlich möchte ich auch nur 0,001% dieser Inhalte bezahlen. Und wäre dazu aber locker bereit und ich denke, dass sich einfach extrem viele Verspannungen auf einmal in den Köpfen lösen würden, wenn man weiß, dass man eine Bezahlung auch im Promille und darunter liegenden Bereich durchführen kann, weil das einfach so Werte sind, die man so selbst kaum spürt oder die vielleicht ganz gut auch abbilden, was man dafür eben zahlen zu zahlen bereit wäre oder bleiben wir einfach mal so im Cent-Bereich. Das man irgendwie jetzt für jeden konsumierten Artikel da halt in entsprechenden Betrag bezahlt. Das wäre das eine, nur das ist einfach nicht realistisch leistbar mit den Verbuchungskonzepten, weil es muss irgendwie dann abgezogen werden, zusammengerechnet werden. Es macht keinen Sinn, da eine Finanztransaktion auf Cent-Basis durchzuführen, beziehungsweise erzeugt dann wiederum zu viel andere Kosten an anderer Stelle. Das ist das eine. Dann kommt halt die Frage auch mit der pauschalen Kontrolle mit rein. Also was, wie schaffe ich es da sozusagen eine Geldbegrenzung zu machen? Die Leute, die sich in Reaktionen auf diese ganze Adblocker-Debatte gemeldet haben, haben gesagt, ich wäre bereit, Betrag X zu bezahlen. In gewisser Hinsicht hat da, glaube ich, jeder auch eine andere Vorstellung davon, was er zu bezahlen in der Lage wäre oder bereit wäre. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das, was aus meinem Kopf herauskommt. Aber wie resoniert das jetzt sozusagen bei dir als Online-Journalist? Inwiefern hast du dir darüber Gedanken gemacht? Welche dieser Modelle wäre eine Bezahl-Abrechnung möglich, dann auch gut funktionieren können?
Also ich habe mir keine tiefer gehenden Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie man Micropayment jetzt irgendwie besonders gut umsetzen kann. Weil ich glaube, das ist auch ein ziemlich kompliziertes Thema. Weil diese Transaktionskosten natürlich irgendwie da und ich habe keine Ahnung von Prozessoren und was da alles in diesem Kreditkartengeschäft zum Beispiel gibt. Und wie man das irgendwie lösen könnte, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, jetzt erstmal so von was wünschenswert wäre.
Was wünschenswert wäre, wäre natürlich eine einfache Möglichkeit, dass der Leser wirklich mit einem Klick bezahlen kann. Dass er sich nur einmal irgendwo anmelden muss, wenn überhaupt. Und dann mit einem Klick eben von seinem Konto einfach einen Centbetrag abwuchen kann. Wodurch natürlich gewisse Formen Journalismus relativ einfach wieder vielleicht zu finanzieren werden. Aber glaube ich auch nicht alles.
Aber wann bezahlt man? Zahlt man vorher oder nachher?
Da ist ja, ich glaube so ein Anreißer ist wahrscheinlich das beste Modell. Also irgendwie zwei Absätze und dann Punkt um Punkt. Und für den Rest bezahlt man, würde ich sagen. Sodass man erst mal nicht die Katze im Sack kauft, sondern dass man ungefähr weiß, worum geht es. Oder was würdest du sagen?
Naja, ich frage ja erstmal dich. Also ich habe da so ein bisschen als Nutzer sichten, ich glaube, dass diese Hürde mit und jetzt ab jetzt musst du bezahlen, immer das Problem hat, dass man sich dann in dem Moment immer wieder diese Frage stellt, ist es mir das jetzt wert oder nicht. Das sind diese mentalen Transaktionskosten, die einfach auch egal wie unwichtig dieser Betrag an der Stelle irgendwie ist, dass man allein, dass man da immer wieder eine Entscheidung fällen muss und immer das Gefühl hat, diese Entscheidung könnte falsch sein.
Ich kenne das von Apps, also auch wenn das 79 Cent sind, denke ich dreimal drüber nach, obwohl ich natürlich für einen Kaffee jetzt mal eben 1,20 ohne den Wimper zu zucken.
Ja gut, aber beim Kaffee weißt du in etwa, was du kriegst. Also da ist dir das sozusagen vorher ziemlich klar, wie das Erlebnis am Ende ist, es sei denn du kaufst da vielleicht das erste Mal und es sieht nach Plörrer aus und dann ist es vielleicht auch Plörrer, aber dann gehst du halt auch nicht wieder hin und dann war es halt auch nur ein Kaffee. Gut, bei Abs ist es in gewisser Hinsicht auch ähnlich, ja. Bloß in dem Moment, wo man eben wirklich breit konsumiert, könnte man das ja auch andersrum denken. Angenommen, es gäbe sozusagen so einen pauschalen Bezahldienst, ja, so eine Art. Ich zahle jetzt mir hier so 30 Euro ein und damit eröffne ich mir so die deutsche Presselandschaft.
Oder wer auch immer daran teilnimmt.
Flatter-Modell, flatter jetzt insofern, als dass ich ja dann diesen Betrag, den ich zahle, auch komplett selber bestimmen kann. Man könnte ja jetzt auch sagen, ich zahle jetzt hier ein bestimmtes Kontingent und das ist dann halt auch irgendwann verbraucht. Und das hält dann eben für so und so viele Artikel vor. Aber ein Artikel hat sozusagen immer denselben Wert. Aber ich muss dann nicht jedes Mal beim Lesen entscheiden, zahle ich jetzt für den oder zahle ich nicht. Ist dieser Teaser jetzt, macht der mich heiß genug oder nicht? Das ist ja dann auch, also an der Stelle ist einfach das Erlebnis eigentlich schon spoilt. Und wenn ich dann einfach nur sage, ja okay, ich muss mich jetzt hier mit meinem, mit meiner Presswallet sozusagen anmelden, ja okay, das ist ja nochmal eine andere Frage, Datenschutz etc., aber dann wird zumindest festgestellt, ah okay, der junge Mann, der jetzt hier angetrappt kommt, der hat auch noch sozusagen das Potenzial, seine Dauerkarte, Presse diesen Monat läuft noch. Kann ja sein, dass man da so einen Pauschalbetrag zahlt für, wenn ich 30, 40, 50 Euro oder was auch immer zahle, dann kann ich halt so viel wie ich will, was auch immer, und wenn ich es halt weniger habe, dann ist es irgendwo beschränkt, wie auch immer, Flatrate-Diskussion. Und dann geht es quasi automatisch. Weil da hängt ja dann auch noch ein anderer Rattenschwatz dran, diese ganze Privatsphäre, wer trackt, was ich lese, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie über mehrere journalistische Erzeugnisse hinaus sozusagen auch noch global getrackt werden kann, was ja teilweise auch heute schon der Fall ist, aber das wäre ja mit so einem Login noch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise möglich, es schafft ja auch wieder Probleme, ja. Aber da ich halt bezahle, könnte ich ja dann eben auch verlangen, dass diese Information eben dann auch bei mir bleibt. Ob das dann stattfindet, ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Also ich denke, dass solche Fragestellungen auf jeden Fall gerade anstehen.
Ja, also ich glaube auch, dass das als Ergänzung auf jeden Fall so eine Art Flat-Chat-Modell und am besten auch über verschiedene Medien hinweg auf jeden Fall ein gutes Angebot wäre. Die Frage ist natürlich, bekommt man da die Verlagern einen Tisch, dass sie wirklich so ein Deal machen, dass alle zusammen sagen, wir schließen unsere Angebote zusammen und dann wird verteilt, wer wie oft irgendwas liest oder so. Also das wäre ja so ein bisschen das Flat-Chat-Modell, dass das dann aufgeteilt wird, die Beträge, was gelesen wird tatsächlich. Ja, ich sehe im Moment nicht, dass die Verlage da so weit sind. Sie sind nicht verzweifelt genug, um sich zusammenzuschließen. Und es wäre vielleicht auch ein bisschen das Problem von Kartellrecht. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern so eine Preisabsprache wäre. Ich kenne mich jetzt nicht so aus dem Kartellrecht, ob das illegal wäre. Aber könnte es Probleme machen.
Preisabsprache inwiefern? Indem sich alle auf denselben Preis einigen sozusagen?
Ja, indem sich alle, dass sie sich absprechen, dass man einen gewissen Preis zahlen muss, um ihre journalistischen Angebote zu lesen. Das sind ja verschiedene Firmen, die sich auf einen Preis einigen. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das unter Kartellrecht fallen würde.
Das stimmt, das ist ein interessanter Aspekt. Da habe ich noch gar nicht so drüber nachgedacht. Also in gewisser Hinsicht können einem die journalistischen Organisationen, ich sage so ungern immer nur Verlage, weil das könnte man auch ganz andere Sachen vorstellen, eigentlich können sie einem leid tun, weil die ganze Last dieser digitalen Innovation irgendwie auf sie drauf fällt. Sie müssen sich im Prinzip mit einem Innovationsfeld auseinandersetzen, der mit ihrer ursprünglichen Tätigkeit der journalistischen Arbeit so gar nichts zu tun hat. Was die BWL-Seite betrifft, sieht das natürlich schon wieder ganz anders aus, weil auch da muss man mit finanziellen Prozessen um sich werfen. Von daher ist das vielleicht auch schon wieder fast ein bisschen übertrieben.
Als Journalist kann ich sagen, ich sehe das Ganze gar nicht unbedingt so negativ, weil es kann ja sein, dass neue journalistische Formate jetzt auch entwickelt werden im Digitalen, die nicht von den jetzt etablierten Verlagen entwickelt werden. Und das kann mir als Journalist ja erstmal egal sein, ob ich dann später jetzt für das neue Start-up arbeite, was dann dieses Format entwickelt hat, oder halt der Verlag. Und bei jeder Disruption war es glaube ich bisher so, dass die Etablierten sich da nicht unbedingt komplett gehalten haben. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt gerade bei der Republika den Dieter Setscher gehört, der gesagt hat, als die Elektro-Lok eingeführt wurde, da hat irgendwie keiner Einziger der Hersteller von Dampflokomotiven überlebt. Weil die halt gesagt haben, das ist Standard-Technik, so ist die Lok und so bleibt die auch. Die haben sich halt nicht angepasst an diese Elektro-Lok-Einführung. Und dann waren halt neue Unternehmen am Markt. Und trotzdem gab es noch Lokführer. Und ich sehe mich da so ein bisschen als Lokführer, weil letztlich braucht es irgendwie Personal, der einen Journalismus in irgendeiner Form an den Mann und die Frau bringt. Und ob das jetzt von dem neuen Start-up erledigt wird, auf der Geschäftsebene oder von entdebierten Verlagen, kann mir ja erstmal egal sein im Grunde, solange mich dafür jemand bezahlt. Also von daher, wenn jetzt neue Innovationen kommen durch Start-ups, warum nicht?
Ausgehend jetzt von dieser Bezahl-Frage, gibt es ja auch durchaus Innovationen zu finden. Was natürlich jetzt hier auch eine große Rolle spielt, ist die Crowd. Oder sagen wir mal, in gewisser Hinsicht auch die Leser. Und eben diese ganze Fragestellung, was für eine Bindung habe ich eigentlich? Wir sind so von diesem einen Extremen, ich habe gar keine Bindung.
Leserbriefe waren das höchste Gefühl.
Ja genau, aber gerade online der Leser als Werbungsklickvieh, der die Bilderstrecken durchgetrieben wird, so mit hier, lauf schneller, click more. Auf der anderen Seite dann eben solche Crowdfunding-Ansätze, wo der Journalismus überhaupt erst bereit ist, aus der Tür zu gehen, bevor ein bestimmter Betrag zusammengetragen worden ist. Was für Modelle siehst du denn da, mit denen experimentiert wurde? Hat da schon mal irgendwas funktioniert?
Im Kleinen funktioniert da einiges. Also Spot Us ist ja in den USA als lokalen Journalismus-Projekt an der Westküste gestartet, ich glaube in San Francisco. Und da werden zum Beispiel regelmäßig Reportagen finanziert. Und es gibt auch in Deutschland so ein paar Beispiele, die funktionieren. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe weiterer, die nicht funktionieren. Ein bisschen ist das Problem beim Crowdfunded-Journalismus, dass man ja nicht unbedingt zahlen muss, um hinterher was davon zu haben. Ich habe das mal genannt, Trittbettfahrerprobleme. Viele dieser Recherchen, die da angestellt werden, Crowdfunded sind ja zum Beispiel nützlich für die ganze Gesellschaft. Also wenn da irgendwie ein Skandal aufgedeckt wird, oder wenn da irgendwie recherchiert wird, wie gut mit Kunden umgeht oder was auch immer. Also in vielen Fällen hat letztendlich die ganze Gesellschaft was davon. Und wenn man das jetzt finanziert, kann man eben andere nicht von dem Nutzen ausschließen, der das Ganze hat. Und viele der Crowdfunded-Sachen sind ja auch hinterher frei im Netz. Das heißt also, man hat so ein bisschen das Problem, anders als beim Produkt-Crowdfunding, wo man halt bezahlt dafür, dass man dann hinterher das Produkt vergünstigt bekommt.
Wenn überhaupt. Also vielleicht auch nicht vergünstigt sein, dass es überhaupt erst mal gemacht wird.
Wobei in den meisten Fällen, also bei Kickstarter und so, ist es ja, glaube ich, so, dass man das dann als Funder schon...
Bisschen billiger kriegt oder noch ein T-Shirt dazu oder eine Kaffeetasse, ja.
Nee, aber in dem Fall ist es halt so, dass am Ende alle bekommen, also alle von den Nutzen profitieren, den das ganze Projekt hat.
Freigekauft wird, sozusagen.
Ja, und da ist halt die Frage, wie altruistisch sind Menschen letztlich? Also, es gibt wahrscheinlich verschiedene Motivationen, warum man jetzt Crowdfunding, Journalismus unterstützt, aber die Motivation, die beim Produkt so im Vordergrund steht, dass ich hinterher persönlich dieses Produkt habe, die ist da, glaube ich, nicht zentral. Und von daher ist das, glaube ich, schwieriger zumindest das Crowdfunding im Journalismus als bei klassischen Produkten. Wobei es halt, wie gesagt, es funktioniert schon, also nur eben im Kleinen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass, ich glaube, dass die Zukunft des Journalismus im Crowdfunding liegt, weil so viele Journalisten, wie wir heute haben, werden sicherlich nicht über Crowdfunding finanziert werden, in Zukunft, glaube ich. Wo es aber ganz gut funktioniert, ist zum Beispiel auch im Bereich wirklich qualitativ hochwertiger Reportagen. Also ein Beispiel ist readmatter.com, wo es im Grunde um wirklich tiefe Analysen, Reportagen, Recherchen geht, die dann finanziert werden, wo dann auch etablierte Journalisten, renommierte Journalisten schreiben und eben auch sehr, sehr ausführlich. Und da ist es dann auch so, glaube ich, dass die Motivation tatsächlich daran liegt, dass man hinter den Artikel lesen darf, weil das ist dann wirklich hinter der Bezahlschranke.
Ja, das ist aber ein Abo-Modell hier, ne?
Ich dachte, das wäre so, dass man einzelne Artikel crowdfunding kann. Oder haben die das?
Ich schaue jetzt nur gerade hier, was mir angeboten wird. Hier ist sowohl von Subscription als auch von Kaufen einer einzelnen Story die Rede. Aber vielleicht gibt es auch noch einen Crowdfunding-Aspekt.
Also ich meine, das hat angefangen mit Crowdfunding auf jeden Fall. Ach so, genau nicht. Es war so, das Portal haben sie ge-crowdfunded. Und die Artikel werden jetzt einfach so gegen Geld verkauft als Abo oder einzelne. Das stimmt ja.
Genau.
Und man kriegt dafür dann E-Books und Audiobooks und Archivzugriffe und so weiter. Das ist halt auch mal wieder diese alte Mehrwert-Geschichte. In gewisser Hinsicht kann man natürlich auch einfach über den Mehrwert marschieren und einfach mal auch etwas anbieten, was so bisher eigentlich noch gar nicht da war. Ja, sozusagen über den Artikel hinaus einfach auch die Convenience des Zugriffs zu besser zu automatisieren, andere Formate anzubieten, das mag hilfreich sein. Aber was mich nochmal beim Crowdfunding-Aspekt sehr interessiert ist, das merkt man ja eigentlich auch generell. Crowdfunding ist eine sehr persönliche Geschichte und hat sehr viel mit Vertrauen und Zugänglichkeit und der Vermittlung der eigenen Persönlichkeit, wenn man was anzubieten hat, zu tun. Beim Journalismus war es lange Zeit so, mit wenigen Ausnahmen, besonders bekannte Autorennamen, die jetzt gerade mal irgendein Gate ausgegraben haben oder besonders sichtbar sind innerhalb einer Publikation, man lebt primär von dem Brand, unter dem man halt schreibt. Das ist ja bei dir jetzt auch nicht anders. Wechselst du sozusagen deinen Arbeitgeber, dann wirst du eben damit assoziiert und dann auch entsprechend immer beschimpft. Oder auch nicht, oder gelobt.
Ich arbeite ja für den bösen Mörder auch.
Genau, das muss man auch gleich ausbaden. Dem Ganzen steht ja dann auch im Netz, gerade durch die Blogger, sehr dieses persönliche Modell im Vordergrund, wo man eben einfach sagt, ich bin meine eigene Marke, ich stehe für meine Arbeit, meine Arbeit steht für mich. Und Leute, die mich dann eben auch unterstützen, tun das eben mehr, umso mehr Bezug sie eben zu meiner Personenmarke haben. Oder es kann sich auch um eine kleinere Gruppe, so eine kleine Kooperative von Journalisten handeln, die jetzt nicht sich gleich Magazine oder was auch immer nennen würden, sondern sich einfach auch vielleicht einen anderen Anstrich geben, was weiß ich, so ein Recherche-Kollektiv, so journalistische Detektive, wie auch immer. Also gerade wenn es um solche Scoops geht, könnte ich mir sowas ganz gut vorstellen. Denkst du, oder wie siehst du, siehst du da überhaupt so einen Trend hin von dem Repräsentiertwerden durch eine große Marke hin zu einem sehr viel direkteren Zugang? Weil du ja im Prinzip, wir reden immer so von direkten Zugang zum Kunden, aber du hast ja quasi immer noch die Indirektion über die Organisation, die natürlich auch für dich eine ganze Menge leistet und auch Produktionssicherheit herstellt durch im Idealfall regelmäßige Gehaltszahlung. Aber diese Schranke könnte ja auch fallen und du könntest überlegen, ich bin jetzt hier als Journalist etabliert, es macht mir viel mehr Spaß, wenn ich meine eigene Audience bediene.
Also diesen Trend gibt es auf jeden Fall. Und es gibt ja auch Theoretiker, die das ganz stark propagieren. Also Jeff Chavez ist wieder der Stichwort, der sagt, Journalisten müssen zu Marke werden und zu Unternehmern. Sie müssen lernen, Unternehmer zu werden, ihre eigene Marke zu etablieren und darüber dann eben zu verkaufen und nicht über irgendwie das Medium, dem sie publizieren. Aktuell ist es so, dass die Leser tatsächlich kaum Journalisten namentlich wahrnehmen. Also es gibt so ein paar Ausnahmen, wie du schon sagtest. Walt Mossberg oder so ist jetzt jemand, der tatsächlich als eigene Marke steht.
Aber das sind ja auch schon so richtige Popstars.
Genau, das ist halt so jemand, den wirklich Millionen Leute kennen. Und ich glaube auch, dass die Anzahl an Marken, die in der breiten Öffentlichkeit etabliert ist in den Köpfen, ist einfach sehr begrenzt. Also könnte sich jetzt nicht jeder 500 Journalisten merken, die für irgendwelche Themen stehen.
Nee, weil wahrscheinlich auch das Interesse an Journalismus an der Stelle gar nicht so doof. Also man würde wahrscheinlich schon über eine ganz andere Zielgruppe nachdenken, nämlich eine Infogeile, die nicht genug kriegen können, die auch, sagen wir mal, so Zeug auch gut weglesen können. Das kann ja auch nicht unbedingt jeder. Nicht jeder ist jetzt in der Lage, das so zu machen. Gut, im Podcasting-Bereich hat man eigentlich so eine ähnliche Bewegung, wenn man es jetzt mal mit dem Radio vergleicht. Da trifft es halt auch eben nur diese bestimmte Zielgruppe, die eben gut weghören kann, was auch wiederum nicht jeder kann. Also manche bevorzugen den Text, manche bevorzugen den Ton, manche bevorzugen das Bild, was vielleicht sogar die allermeisten sind. Aber trotzdem in all diesen Bereichen sehe ich zumindest Versuche einer solchen Personalisierung.
Also es gibt die Versuche im Journalismus auf jeden Fall auch und es gibt viele, die das propagieren und es gibt viele Journalisten, die jetzt bei Twitter aktiv sind und versuchen, sich da so eine Marke aufzubauen. Ich glaube, das funktioniert immer nur im begrenzten Maße in dem eigenen Umfeld. Also wenn jemand immer wieder über die Autobranche berichtet, dann ist der sicherlich irgendwann unter Leuten, die sich genau für seine Unternehmen interessieren und unter den Presse sprechen usw., ist er dann natürlich irgendwann bekannt. Dann funktioniert das. Aber dass sich der Journalist direkt an die Öffentlichkeit als Marke wendet, das kann, glaube ich, nur für einen ganz kleinen Teil der Journalisten funktionieren. Wie gesagt, weil einfach die Kapazität der meisten Leute in der Öffentlichkeit, sich Leute zu merken, also auch der Wille, ist eben einfach begrenzt. Und da merken sich die Leute eben dann doch lieber, Handelsblatt steht für Wirtschaft, als der Herr Müller steht für Siemens Berichterstattung und IG oder ähnliches. Also da stößt man, glaube ich, einfach auf Grenzen des Interesses und der Aufnahmefähigkeit. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das so funktioniert, dass sich viele Journalisten, also es gibt welche, die es können, und es sind ja auch nochmal ganz andere Fähigkeiten, die es dann auch benötigt. Also jemand, der gut schreiben kann, kann sich deswegen noch nicht unbedingt gut verkaufen. Und es gibt eben viele Journalisten, die das eine halt immer noch gut können und die gut recherchieren können und so weiter, aber halt trotzdem nicht so eine Rampensau sind, dann auch irgendwie überall auf Kongresse zu gehen und Vorträge zu halten und so weiter und sich dadurch als Marke zu etablieren. Und für solche Leute, also die sollten mal dann auch eben auch noch die Chance haben, zu publizieren und das ist dann eben unter so einem Mantel von einer Marke ganz gut.
Ja klar, aber ich meine, der Einzelkämpfer jetzt als das maximale Extrem zu dem großen Verlag, das muss ja nicht die einzige Antwort sein. Wie ich gerade schon sagte, also auch in dem Moment, wo man so ein kleineres Kollektiv bildet, was natürlich dann auch sehr viel besser absichert, also da kann man sich dann besser die Arbeit teilen. Der eine kann sich vielleicht auch eben mehr in diese Vermarktung der Gruppe, dieses Mini-Brands konzentrieren und während andere dann eben der einlichen Arbeit nachgehen. Ich denke auch, dass so eine gewisse Abkopplung vom Namen ja gerade bei Journalisten manchmal auch ganz hilfreich ist, weil man ja auch nicht unbedingt zu bekannt werden will, weil wenn man dann irgendwie in sensitiven Bereichen recherchiert, gleich alle Alarmglocken losgehen, ist sicherlich auch nochmal so ein ähnlicher Problemfall. Der zeigt sich ja auch bei diesem Crowdfunding. Also Crowdfunding heißt ja im Prinzip auch, ich berichte schon vorher darüber, was für ein Skandal ich jetzt aufdenken will und dann gehen natürlich irgendwie alle gleich in Deckung. Wie kann man das lösen?
Tja, gute Frage. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so die spontane Antwort darauf.
Also im Endeffekt muss es doch auch so Online-Journalisten, die unterhalten sich doch auch bestimmt untereinander. Da muss es doch irgendwie einen Trend und eine Meinungsbildung geben. Es sind ja nicht alle jetzt irgendwie nur hörig irgendwie ihrer Verlage erlegen. Was ist denn da so?
Also ich glaube, die Idee, sich wirklich von Verlagen abzukoppeln, haben wirklich jetzt die wenigsten. Also es gibt ja so Leute, die so viel Crowdfunding machen, bei Twitter und so weiter. Es sind aber meistens Leute, die dann auch freie Journalisten sind. Das heißt, sie sind sowieso nicht abhängig jetzt von einem Verlag oder so. Sie machen halt sowieso eine Mischfinanzierung und für die ist Crowdfunding halt ein weiterer Einnahmenkanal unter vielen. Mehr kann das momentan auch für die allermeisten nicht sein. Und wenn man zu Bezahlmodellen käme, dann wäre das, glaube ich, ein gangbarer Weg, wie du eben sagtest, dass man sich in Kooperationen zusammenschließt und Recherchen anstellt und so weiter. Solange wir halt dieses Werbe-Massengeschäft haben. Werbung ist halt ein Massengeschäft absolut in Deutschland. Also es lohnt sich einfach nicht, für eine kleine Zielgruppe Online-Werbung anzubieten. Das sind einfach solche Mini-Beträge, dass es für keinen sich irgendwie lohnt. Und das lohnt sich auch nicht für die Vermarkter, weil die für kleine Beträge gar nicht ein Telefonhörer abnehmen. Solange das eben das nominierende Geschäftsmodell im Netz ist, sehe ich da nicht die große Chance zu sein. Also wenn, dann müssten wir halt wieder wirklich zu Bezahlmodellen kommen. Also entweder Crowdfunding oder andere Modelle. Dann könnte das funktionieren. Aber es ist momentan auf jeden Fall kein großer Trend. Also es gibt so ein paar junge Journalisten, die wie gesagt auf freier Basis arbeiten. Viele so im Bereich öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk und so. Daniel, wie heißt er nochmal? Daniel Backendorf oder so. Der macht jetzt, glaube ich, gerade auch so ein Crowdfunding.
Meinst du diese Krautreporter-Geschichte? Oder verwechsel ich da was?
Kann sein, dass sie das so nennen. Die recherchieren gerade zum Thema Datenschutz, wo ich jetzt sagen muss, das ist jetzt nicht so ein Thema, wo ich noch mal mir mehr anhören muss.
Ich dachte, du meinst jetzt das Portal. Also es gibt ja so krautreporter.de, also kraut im Sinne von Deutsch.
Ach so, okay, nee, das meint man nicht. Also ich glaub, mich das dazu gehört. Aber es gibt halt so ein paar, die experimentieren. Es gibt auch Tilo Jung, der mit seinem Format Jung und Naiv immerhin so über 5000 Euro, ich glaub 6000 Euro oder so was eingesammelt hat. So ein Video-Format bei YouTube. Im Kleinen funktioniert das alles, aber es ist jetzt nicht der große Trend aktuell, den ich da sehe.
Gut, ich meine, wenn das jetzt alles so prekär ist, es gibt ja auch eine andere Seite, in dem Moment, wo Journalisten schlecht bezahlt werden, dann hat man natürlich auch das Problem der mangelnden Unabhängigkeit. Und dass man dann eben sich auch schnell auf so bezahlte, fast schon, ja kriminell ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber zumindest in ihrer Legitimität etwas fragwürdige Aufbereitung der Inhalte hat. Worüber schreibe ich? Schreibe ich da drüber, was irgendwie auf der nächsten Seite dann als ganz flächige Anzeige auch gleich wieder reflektiert wird? Hast du da irgendwie eine Wahrnehmung, wie sich das so entwickelt?
Also ich glaube, im Lokaljournalismus war das immer schon in gewissem Maße Gang und Gerbe.
So Wochenblätter.
Nicht nur da, also wirklich auch richtige Tageszeitungen auf regionaler Ebene. Da gibt es immer eine ganz große Nähe zwischen, also erstmal gibt es da so eine große Nähe zwischen Berichterstattern und die, über die Berichterstattet wird. Weil man kennt sich, man hilft sich. Es ist da immer ganz eng irgendwie. Und da ist sowas auch wie, wir schalten eine Anzeige und dafür macht ihr einen Artikel, ist da leider tatsächlich verbreitet. Also kann ich sagen, habe ich Informationsklient für. Das ist jetzt nicht bei jeder und auch weniger bei den Großen. Und eher bei den Kleinen und eher bei den Boulevardesten-Tagesaitungen. Aber das gibt es da auf jeden Fall. Bei den größeren Zeitungen ist das nicht so einfach. Also es ist nicht so, dass jetzt beim großen etablierten Titel, dass da wirklich direkt Einfluss genommen wird im Einzelfall. Wobei das kann immer sein, dass irgendwie einer persönlich da eine Verbindung hat, das will ich nicht ausschließen. Aber so systematisch wird das nicht gemacht. Was es gibt, ist, dass auch gerade online viel so in Richtung Special-Vermarktung geht. Es wird dann immer ganz gerne mal Sonderbeilage oder so was, auch im Print genannt. Also das ist im Grunde, irgendein Kunde kauft ein Thema. Nicht die Berichterstattung, was genau gesagt werden soll, sondern das darüber berichtet wird, kauft ein Kunde. Und dann wird sozusagen um die Anzeigen herum redaktioneller Text gebaut. Diesen Trend gibt es schon sehr stark. Und den gibt es auch online sehr stark, also Specials.
Mach doch mal was über Carsharing oder so. Tja, aber das muss ja verhindert werden eigentlich.
Das wäre schön.
Wir wünschen uns eine blumenumrangte Zukunft von aseptischen, frei von Einflüssen, hochengagierten Journalismus. Was kann denn da... Ich denke, wir sind auch beide so ein bisschen in dieser Generation, wir sind immer so grundoptimistisch, was das Internet betrifft. Das ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich. Wir sind automatisch beseelt und denken immer so, das muss doch auch besser gehen. Das kann ja wohl nicht alles schlecht sein. Während die alte Dampflok-Abteilung den Untergang der Zivilisation herbeizubeten scheint, wenn auch nur irgendwie was das mit Bits und digitaler Speicherung zu tun hat. Die Wahrheit liegt natürlich wie immer irgendwo dazwischen. Diese Disruption, die ja zwangsläufig stattfindet. Und hier wirklich sozusagen ein etabliertes Geschäftsmodell in seinen Grundfesten erschüttert. Das muss man ja auch mal fairerweise sagen. Die haben es auch nicht einfach. Das habe ich vorhin auch schon versucht so anzudeuten. Die können einem schon fast so ein bisschen Leid tun, weil ja nicht wirklich alle Branchen in demselben Maße so auf breiter Front da Lehrgeld zahlen müssen. Also es prasselt wirklich von allen Seiten ein. Das Geld irgendwie bricht weg. Der Leser wird auf einmal kritisch. Der kann irgendwie auch einfach mal mit publizieren, ja, und schießt zurück und zwingt einen zu Stellungnahmen, was sonst wirklich nur der größte Ausnahmefall gewesen ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es definitiv eine Möglichkeit zur Innovation, die dann eben auch einfach mal zweierlei Lösungen bringt, nämlich einerseits für einen selbst, als Journalisten überhaupt auch eine andere Plattform, auch eine andere Überlebensplattform zu bieten, aber dann letztlich eben auch für die Leser quasi eine Weiterentwicklung dieses Ganze, dass man eben auch einfach in einer Qualität berichten kann, wie es so noch nicht der Fall war. Mir würden dazu zwei Sachen einfallen, die du tatsächlich schon angesprochen hast, die fehlen so ein bisschen nebenbei, nämlich einfach auch so diese Weiterentwicklung der journalistischen Formate, vor allem dieser Datenjournalismus, wie das so schön genannt wird. Also was ich so ein bisschen auch... Na ja, der Name ist gar nicht so schlecht, aber er verwirrt so ein bisschen, weil es impliziert ja so, als hätte es vorher keine Daten gegeben oder man hätte sowas nicht ausgewertet. Ich würde es fast eher so ein bisschen programmieren, Journalismus, dass man eben sehr viel mehr darüber nachdenkt, Auswertung und Analyse und Interpretation mehr aus diesem Gefühl und dem einfachen Nachrechnen herauszunehmen hin zu einer systematischen Auswertung der Ist-Situation. Das zeigt sich ja dann eben sehr schön bei diesen Visualisierungen. Man nimmt halt große Statistikdaten, plotet mal ein paar schöne Karten und aha, auf einmal kommen da irgendwie Aspekte raus, die es so vorher noch nicht gab. Mehr noch, man erstellt Werkzeuge, also das Endergebnis ist mehr als nur geschriebener Text und eine Bewertung. Sondern man schafft ja tatsächlich Software. Man bietet zumindest für einen überschaubaren Bereich ein Tool, wo dann jeder irgendwie selber was anklicken kann. Und es geht halt schon deutlich über die Präsentation von Wahlergebnissen hinaus. Und damit vermittelt man natürlich auch die gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhänge.
Jetzt geht es wieder um die Geschichten erzählen. Computer Assisted Journalism ist natürlich so ein Begriff, der schon in den 60er Jahren aufgekommen ist. Also mit Daten haben Journalisten sowieso immer schon gearbeitet. Und dann kam der Computer dazu und hat eben dann auch die Möglichkeit erweitert, mit Daten zu arbeiten. Und jetzt geht es wirklich beim Data Driven Journalism, oder wie man es auch immer nennen will, oder Datenjournalismus, darum, das so aufzubereiten, dass man das Online-Format eben so nutzt, dass man das Medium eben ausnutzen, seine Fähigkeiten, und dann eben auch Darstellungsformen findet, die diese Daten eben visualisieren und dann eben auch interaktive Modelle daraus macht, sodass der Leser eben selber auch Dinge erforschen kann und vielleicht auch zum Beispiel auf Dinge stoßen kann, auf die der Jurist gar nicht gestoßen ist. Also wenn man wirklich dem Leser dieses Tool an die Hand gibt, dann kann er auch Dinge noch entdecken, die man selber aus den Daten gar nicht herausgelesen hat und durch Feedback und so weiter kann das auch wieder verbreitet werden. Da sind wir noch ganz am Anfang und da hat ja auch schon gesagt, dass New York Times und Guardian da auch ziemlich weit vorne sind bei der Nutzung dieser Formate und das ist auf jeden Fall spannend, was das noch bringt.
Ist das für dich ein Thema? Also ich meine, kannst du programmieren?
Nee, ich kann nicht programmieren. Ich kenne mich auf einer Metaebene ein bisschen aus mit Programmieren. Ich weiß, was möglich ist und was nicht. Ich kenne Programmierer und kenne mich mit dem Thema ein bisschen aus, aber ich kann es selber nicht, habe es selber nie gemacht. Und ich habe auch noch kein datenjournalistisches Projekt durchgeführt.
Das hält dich zurück. Also gerade so in der Finanzwelt ist ja nicht so, dass da keine Zahlen geben, an die man sich mal heranpushen könnte.
Das stimmt natürlich, ja. Ja, ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Idee. Also, wie gesagt, da ich nicht programmieren kann, müsste... Also ich hatte sogar schon mal so etwas angestoßen, noch beim Handelsbett mit Open Data City, die ja viel machen in dem Bereich. Ist aber nicht vorangekommen, weil immer an irgendeiner Stelle dann doch nicht das Okay gegeben wurde. Wäre vielleicht auch noch mal eine Möglichkeit, das anzustoßen. Auch da ist natürlich wieder das Problem, dass so eine Grafik, so schön sie dann auch ist, jetzt nicht unbedingt der Klickgenerator ist. Also das ist auch wieder eher so was, was in so ein Bezahlmodell vielleicht dann fallen würde, wo sich das dann lohnen würde, als jetzt bei dem bisher, wie es jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, weil hier ist ja sozusagen ein anderer Mehrwert. Hier würde man quasi mehrere Disziplinen miteinander kombinieren. Ich bin in der Lage, Daten automatisiert auszuwerten auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. Ich gebe dem Ganzen einen journalistischen Spin, weil ich weiß, aus welchen Daten heraus sich gegebenenfalls Sensitives generieren lässt. der Journalist müsste diese Daten auch überhaupt erst mal holen. Manches, was derzeit im Datenjournalismus gemacht wird, das sind ja meistens total offensichtliche Sachen. Erst wird immer geschrien nach offenen Daten, dann werden sie mal geöffnet, dann litten sie sich runter, dann macht man was drauf und das Ergebnis ist interessant. Aber eben auch mal so komplexes Datenmaterial überhaupt erst mal so detektivisch auszugraben und dann, wenn man sie eben bekommt, dann entsprechend auszuwerten. Es gab ja gerade diesen Offshore-Leaks-File bzw. diese ganzen Wikileaks-Datenmengen. Darüber kann man jetzt diskutieren, inwieweit das eine journalistische Leistung war, an diese Daten überhaupt erst mal heranzukommen. Nichtsdestotrotz stehen die auf einmal dort. Dann müssen sie auch mit einer gewissen Gesellschaftsintelligenz angegangen werden. Weil man nicht einfach nur sagen kann, die summieren wir jetzt mal, weil dann kommt ja kein relevantes Ergebnis bei raus.
Ja, was ist genau die Frage?
Ich versuche nur, diese Diskussion anzuregen, was sich einfach noch so entwickeln könnte oder wo du vielleicht ähnliche Projekte auch schon gesehen hast, die sich in diese Richtung bewegen könnten.
Also, es gibt erstmal die Möglichkeit, auch wieder Crowdsourcing anzuwenden. Es gibt zum Beispiel von Paul Bradshaw, das ist so ein Medienwissenschaftler in Großbritannien. Der hat ein Portal eröffnet, wo Leute vor Ort Daten eingeben können. Man muss erstmal die Datenbasis haben, die relevant sind. Da können Bürger fragen, warum ist hier vor meiner Tür der Baum gefällt worden? Ganz einfache Fragen vor Ort. Dann können andere darauf antworten. Das ist eine Plattform, wo Daten gesammelt werden. Darüber hinaus haben wir in Deutschland immer noch weniger von Regierungsseite zur Verfügung stehende Daten als in anderen Ländern. In USA und Großbritannien gibt es Informationsfreiheitsgesetze, die es zwar in Deutschland im Prinzip auch gibt, aber die in Deutschland nicht so konsequent umgesetzt werden. Man muss dafür zahlen, dass man dann irgendwelche Auskünfte bekommt. In USA gibt es OpenData.gov und in Großbritannien gibt es opendata.uk. Das heißt, da ist die Maschinenlesbare Regierung, die früher gefordert wurde, schon deutlich weiter. Da sind wir in Deutschland noch ziemlich am Anfang. Es fehlt momentan noch viel an der Frage, wie man an Daten herankommt. Man muss sich am Anfang die Frage stellen, was eine relevante Frage ist. Man will ja auch dort einen Journalismus nicht aus Selbstzweck machen, sondern man muss ja auch fragen, welche relevante Frage kann man beantworten aus Daten? Das ist der Ansatzpunkt der Recherche. Ich habe da noch nicht so viel gesehen. Du hast selber Offshore-Leaks genannt und Wikileaks, die an Afghanistan das aufbereitet haben. Das waren tatsächlich so Sachen, wo man tatsächlich sehr relevante Erkenntnisse aus Daten herleiten konnte.
Und auch teilweise per Crowdsourcing, wenn es auch nicht unbedingt jetzt immer die komplette Masse war, sondern wo auch viele Journalisten in einem Netzwerk an so etwas im Geheimen dann gearbeitet haben. Also wo man sich auch ein bisschen zumindest von diesem Modell getrennt hat. Die Information liegt dann in der Redaktion und die drei Leute, die um den Tisch herum stehen, die kümmern sich dann halt drum, aber bloß nichts weiter sagen. Bis hin zu einer globalen Konspiration, die dann immer noch genauso verdeckt arbeiten, aber die das eben auch mit sehr viel mehr Schultern sozusagen tragen, dieses Projekt.
Genau, und am Ende geht es auch immer wieder eigentlich darum, das eine ist natürlich diese Darstellungsform, die man auf der Website gut umsetzen kann, aber man muss auch irgendwie aus diesen Daten, man will am Ende nicht einfach nur die Daten den Leuten vor das Gesicht klatschen, sondern man will daraus dann wieder Geschichten erzählen. Das ist eigentlich immer, was dann wieder am Ende dieses Prozesses steht. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich versuchen, aus all diesen Daten, auch in Teamarbeit und so weiter, dann eben eine Geschichte dann wieder zu erzählen.
Aber um so Sachen wie Crowdfunding und Crowdsourcing, und damit ja im Prinzip auch das Potenzial für eine größere Unabhängigkeit einzelner Journalisten bzw. zumindest bestimmter Gruppen und kleinerer Gruppen von Journalisten, die noch nicht gleich ein Verlag sind. Um das sozusagen zu befördern, habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass da fehlt noch so ein bisschen so die Fan-Crowd für Journalismus. Also Journalismus selbst hat sich irgendwie lange Zeit eben so, wenn wir es im Eingang schon hatten, so ein bisschen so abgehoben, elfenbeintommäßig, selbst inszeniert, so ein bisschen die Wichtigkeit aus sich selbst heraus abgeleitet und dabei so ein bisschen die Leute auch verloren. Und deswegen gibt es auch so hektische und teilweise auch so aufgeladene Debatten, wie man sie jetzt mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht erlebt hat. Müsste man nicht diesen, ist das nicht sozusagen etwas, ist das nicht eine interessante Front, an der man jetzt eigentlich investieren müsste, um da sozusagen die Herzen wieder zu gewinnen? Gerade eben vielleicht auch durch solche Projekte, die sich vielleicht nicht auf den ersten Blick total als die Monetarisierungskür da ergeben, aber einfach, um überhaupt erst mal so eine Fanbase wieder zu erzeugen, die sagen, ja cool, hier Online-Journalismus, ja wie geil, da gehe ich doch nicht zum Justin Bieber-Konzert, wenn ich hier irgendwie auch eine Recherche über die Finanzplätze Deutschlands finanzieren kann.
Also Winning the Hearts and Minds, so laut Bush. Ja, also ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich, ist offenbar eine interessante Front und da wird nicht viel getan, jetzt von Verlagseite, habe ich das Gefühl, und auch bei den meistentablierten Journalisten ist das nicht so, dass sie sich wirklich aus der Deckung wagen und in die Öffentlichkeit gehen und sagen, ich bin hier und spreche mich an und ich will euch erklären, was ich mache und das ist cool. Aber es gibt natürlich jetzt gerade in der jüngeren Generation viele, oder ja, viele ist relativ, aber es gibt sie auf jeden Fall. Es gibt die, die rausgehen und die auf Konferenzen sind und die irgendwie versuchen, Leute zu überzeugen davon, dass das, was sie machen, wichtig ist. Und das ist auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, auch ein ganz wichtiger Schlüssel-Element bei der ganzen Geschichte, wenn wir aus den Lesern auch wirklich wieder Fans machen wollen. Ich glaube, einer, der da ganz relativ aktiv ist, ist Stefan Plöchinger, der Chefredakteur von süddeutscher.de, der auch immer viel darüber spricht, dass er eigentlich erreichen möchte, dass die Leser von der Süddeutschen auch sich identifizieren mit der Marke und damit dann irgendwie auch, ja, sich als Teil dieser Community führen und dann eben süddeutsche Leser sind. Also das ist auch so was, worüber man sich dann eben zum Stück auch definiert. Und dann kann das auch wieder besser funktionieren mit Bezahlmodellen wahrscheinlich. Also ich meine, das ist auch ein bisschen so wie die Popstars, die lange Zeit einfach davon gelebt haben, dass ihre Platten dann millionenfach gepresst wurden und irgendwann gab es Internet und dann konnte sich das runterladen. Jetzt müssen sie halt wieder vor Ort sein, Konzerte geben, Fanartikel verkaufen. Also das ist wieder mehr so die Marke Popstar im Vordergrund und das Erlebnis mit dem Popstar und nicht so sehr das digitale Gut, was jeder eben runterladen kann.
Ja, aber was könnte an der Stelle helfen?
Ich hatte es schon ein bisschen angedeutet, Texas Tribune in den USA Leser einladen, mit Experten diskutieren lassen, also die Zahlen eben dann, also eine Community aufbauen, als Journalist präsent sein in sozialen Netzwerken, offen sein für die Leser und denen das einfach nahebringen und einfach eben nicht sich abschotten im Elfenbeinturm und von oben herab die Welt erklären, sondern eben vom hohen Roster herabsteigen und erreichbar sein für den Leser und erklären, was man eigentlich tut und warum es gut ist.
Ich meine, es ist immer schwierig, wenn man so einen großen Tanker umdrehen will und so, der braucht dann immer eine Weile. Da könnte man ja dann vielleicht auch, oder wäre es vielleicht eine Idee, mit so einer Art Projekt-Spinoff zu arbeiten, sozusagen sich so kleine Beibote zuzulegen, wo man so die innovativen Journalisten so Start-up-mäßig erstmal eine Weile am Leben hält und sagt, hier denkt euch doch mal was aus, sozusagen so lokal angedockte Inkubatoren, wo so Ideen ausgebrütet werden und kommt mal irgendwie, kommt mal selber auf eine Idee, gibt es so etwas? Oder sind das dann immer nur so die, ich hatte so lange so den Eindruck, dass online an sich so ein bisschen so das ist, was ihr wollt euch austoben, na dann geht doch hier ins Internet, da könnt ihr nicht viel kaputt machen, das ist ihr alles nur Quatsch.
Ja, das stimmt. Also online, also bei Spiegel online war es zum Beispiel tatsächlich so, das habe ich mal von jemandem gehört, der gesagt hat, da war das ein Experimentierfeld, also in den 90er Jahren, von jungen Journalisten, die sich dann austoben durften.
Na hat ja ganz gut funktioniert an sich.
Das hat funktioniert, das stimmt, ja. Aktuell gibt es da wirklich wenig. Also ich glaube auch, dass das ein guter Weg wäre. Ich habe auch selber schon mal so etwas, als ich noch beim Handelsbad war, mit angestoßen. Und dann durch den Wechsel ist das jetzt verhindert worden. Da war geplant, auch so eine Art Online-Magazin zu etablieren. Und ich habe die Idee für so eine Art Online-Magazin immer noch und würde sie immer noch gerne umsetzen. Also die Idee, um vielleicht ganz kurz zu skizzieren, war, dass man eben so eine Art Wikipedia für das Nachrichtenwissen bietet. Also dass man nicht die Nachricht bietet, sondern die Nachricht erklärt und auch eben sich auf die großen Nachrichten konzentriert. Also so ein bisschen das Hintergrund. Genau, dass man das Tool hat, um Nachrichten überhaupt zu verstehen. Das sollte die Seite sozusagen werden. Weil ich glaube, der Bedarf dafür ist relativ groß, also gerade auch unter jungen Leuten. Ich habe auch oft Leuten die Idee gesagt, sondern haben sie auch gesagt, dass ihnen genau so etwas fehlt eigentlich.
Stimmt, weil er häufig auch so diese Reportage auch so in ihrem ganzen Duktus und in ihrem Begriffsfeld setzt. Er setzt einfach viel voraus, dass man das irgendwie alles weiß. Dass man die Leute kennt, dass man diese Organisationen kennt, dass man irgendwie weiß, welche palästinensische Volksfront da jetzt gerade in den letzten Jahrzehnten wie gewirkt hat, um überhaupt sowas lesen zu können. Was ich ganz interessant finde im Zusammenhang ist diese Fernsehen, diese Logo für Kindernachrichten, die im Prinzip nach diesem selben Modell funktionieren. Also die versuchen sozusagen Kindern den Kontext von Nachrichten selbst zu kriegen. Ich schaue es nicht regelmäßig, aber ich fand es sehr interessant, gerade vor allem diese potenziell immer so kritischen Nachrichten, wo man denkt, wie sage ich es meinem Kinder, hier in Syrien bringen sich jetzt irgendwie alle um. Dann kommt so dieses große, wie kleidet man das ein? Das ist natürlich das eine. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht denke ich, gibt es eben auch sehr viele Leute, die man natürlich nicht mit so einer Kindsprache, aber zumindest mit so einer Erklärbär-Ansatz an Nachrichten heranführen kann. Ich denke, das hat durchaus Potenzial. Das wäre eben auch wirklich mal ein ganz anderer Einstieg, weil man irgendwie nicht versucht, nur dasselbe anders zu machen, sich wundert, dass es nicht funktioniert, sondern dass man eben auch wirklich mal was Neues mit einbringt.
Das Problem ist natürlich immer, wenn es Unternehmen schlecht geht, dann sind sie nicht so offen für Experimente, dann ist das Geld irgendwie knapp, und so eine Sache wäre natürlich erst mal ein Zuschussgeschäft. Man kann halt nicht von heute auf morgen eine Marke aufbauen, die so viel Reichweite hat, dass das irgendwie...
Aber in dem Moment, wo man jetzt auch Crowdfunding anschößt und sagt, wir versuchen jetzt auch mal wirklich eine ganz andere Sache zu verfolgen, die jetzt nicht irgendwie dasselbe in grün ist, und jetzt berichten wir wie immer, aber nur über was anderes, also ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Gener, denke ich, das sind dann auch so die Sachen, wo dann Leute auch anfangen mitzugehen, weil auch so die Innovation belohnt wird.
Glaubst du, dass das unter einer Verlagsmarke funktionieren könnte?
Also... Ja, ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass so eine Verlagsmarke das verhindert, dass das funktioniert. Deswegen sage ich ja, wenn man so ein Subbrand dann sozusagen, wo vielleicht auch erstmal gar nicht klar ist, was das ist.
Okay, der gute Impresso muss natürlich immer stehen, wer dahinter steht. Also ich kann mir nur ein bisschen vorstellen, dass die Unterstützungsbereitschaft der Crowd leiden würde, wenn das jetzt ein großer Verlag anstößt.
Ja, es sei denn, der Verlag macht von vornherein klar, welcher Grad an Unabhängigkeit vorherrscht.
Ja, aber viele würden trotzdem sagen, warum sollte ich jetzt den großen Verlag XY-mal im Geld unterstützen?
Weil das Projekt als Beiboot so ausgesetzt worden ist, im Sinne von, wenn ihr es schafft, uns von neuen Ideen zu überzeugen, dann finden wir euch cool. Dazu müsst ihr erstmal cool gefunden werden.
Die Wahrnehmung des Verlags würde ja, glaube ich, durch die klassischen Formate dominiert werden und nicht durch dieses neue experimentelle Beiboot.
Ich halte das für ein lösbares Problem. Wie man das auch immer letztlich ausgestaltet, muss man natürlich dann schauen.
Also wie gesagt, wir hatten das ja tatsächlich auch geplant damals da und das ist dann durch meinen Weggang verhindert worden.
Siehst du mal, weil halt die Dinge nicht an dir kleben, musst dich mehr als eigene Marke definieren. Dann kommen die Projekte immer mit.
Ja, aber das meiste kann man eben doch nicht ganz alleine machen. Das ist dann vielleicht auch das Problem. Man braucht ein paar Mitstreiter. Und ich hatte auch tatsächlich auch schon darüber nachgedacht, das in meiner Freizeit noch zu verfolgen, diesen Ansatz. Aber dafür ist mir dann doch die Freizeit zu schade, um sie komplett dann noch für so ein nebenberufliches Projekt zu investieren.
Ja.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch so ein paar Dritte, die so aus ihrer –wir sind ja im Netz und wir können ja machen, was wir wollen –Attitüde heraus auch versuchen, so mit den Erzeugnissen als solches anders umzugehen bzw. auch den ganzen Social-Media-Ströme mehr in so eine journalistische Auswertung zu bringen. Was weiß ich hier, so Systeme wie StoryFi, also ich baue mir mein eigenes Magazin selbst oder Flipboard. Ja, wo sozusagen so aus meinem eigenen, wo ich sozusagen als Leser selbst wieder zu einem Kurator werde und für andere Leute dann quasi so eine teilredaktionelle Tätigkeit mache, so quasi wie die Huffington Post, das mit einer Redaktion macht, irgendwie so, dann sind wir wieder beim Anfang bei Herrn Brecht. Nicht nur jeder ist ein Sender, sondern jeder ist potenziell auch eine Redaktion. Genau, auch ein Filter. Ja, solche Modelle zu machen. Was findest du da an der Stelle noch erwähnenswert? Wie denkst du darüber?
Ich glaube, dass das Potenzial in dieser Hinsicht noch lange nicht ausgeschöpft ist. Ich habe mir selber mal darüber Gedanken gemacht aus meiner Perspektive als speziell Wirtschaftsjournalist. Ich glaube, dass durchaus ein Bedarf danach besteht, dass Leute sagen, ich will eine App haben, wo mir wirklich nur die relevanten Informationen gezeigt werden. Da gibt es die Möglichkeit, Software-Argorithmen einzusetzen, dass man erstmal eine kurze Frage bogen, welche Aktien besitzt du, welches Unternehmen arbeitest du, welche Branche ist das, welche Divisen-Kurse sind relevant, erstmal eine einfache Abfrage. Dann könnte diese App tatsächlich lernen, welche Dinge für diesen Leser wirklich interessant sind. Was da momentan noch fehlt, ist der Zugriff auf die Inhalte. Wir müssen eigentlich kombinieren, ein Software-Algorithmus, der das wirklich gut hinbekommt, mit dem Zugriff auf alle Inhalte. Da könnte man dann ein paar Lizenzmodelle vereinbaren mit den Verlagen. Ich glaube, da gibt es auch wirklich Möglichkeiten. Ich habe mich schon mal ein bisschen vorinformiert. Also, Süddeutsche und so, die lizenzieren ihre Inhalte auch gegen Geld. Man könnte dann per Abruf oder was auch mal da bezahlen. Ich glaube, da wird noch einiges kommen in diesem Bereich. Individualisierte Nachrichten, weil das momentan noch relativ wenig genutzt wird. Und wenn dann nur in Kombination mit komplett freien Web-Inhalten. Jetzt Flipboard zum Beispiel ist ja wirklich nur die freien Inhalte, die man im Web sowieso hat und das ist einfach nur ein Filter dafür. Funktioniert aber auch ganz gut. Aber das kann man halt noch professionalisieren und kann eben auch Zugriff geben auf, jetzt zum Beispiel im Wirtschaftsbereich, Reutas, Bloomberg und so. Da gibt es ja wirklich dann Platzhirsche, Informationen, die man einfach braucht, wenn man da in irgendeiner Manager-Position ist. Und da gibt es für diesen Filter, ich meine, Inhalte gibt es halt wie gesagt, wir sind am Meer im Netz. Aber für diesen intelligenten Filter, da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch noch Leute, die bereit sind, Geld zu bezahlen. Dieser Trend dann dahin zu individualisierter Nachricht, sehe ich aber nicht nur positiv. Also aus gesellschaftlicher Sicht.
Die Streuung wegfällt sozusagen.
Man sieht dann nur noch das, was man hier schon mag. Ja genau, also dieser Blaseneffekt. Da wird ja auch im Internet viel diskutiert. Wir leben in unserer Blase. Der würde einfach noch stärker werden. Und der wurde ja auch schon stärker durch die Medienvielfalt. Und ich glaube mir, als Gesellschaft braucht man so ein bisschen das gemeinsame Narrativ. Irgendwas, woran alle andocken können.
Im Mainstream?
Ja, also man kann das Mainstream natürlich sehr negativ belegen.
Oder Light-Medien.
Man kann das auch Light-Medium nennen. Ich meine jetzt nicht, dass die Light-Medien ihre Funktion immer gut wahrgenommen haben oder immer gut berichtet haben. Aber zumindest gab es ja in der Zeit der Light-Medien, und es gibt ja auch Light-Medien heute noch, wobei sie halt eine Relevanz verloren haben, es gab zumindest immer sowas, dass sich Leute noch untereinander verständigen konnten. Also auch wenn sie aus ganz verschiedenen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen kommen, haben sie trotzdem immer noch so ein bisschen gemeinsame Themen und haben immer noch eine gemeinsame Sprache irgendwie. Und wenn sich alles zu sehr, also wenn jeder zu sehr in seiner Blase nur noch verharrt, und man sieht das ja auch bei Piraten z.B. sehr stark, die existieren oft den ganzen Tag über Themen, die den Rest der Gesellschaft zu großen Teilen nicht wirklich interessiert. Und so kann man auch irgendwie nicht wirklich Einfluss auf die Gesellschaft und auf die Politik nehmen, wenn man sich nur noch in diesen Blasen irgendwie unterhält. Und insofern sehe ich dann so ein bisschen Funktionen von Light Media auch so eine Geschichte zu erzählen, wo eben auch ein Großteil der Gesellschaft sagen kann, ja, so wahr ist. Man muss sich erstmal darauf einigen, was eigentlich gerade überhaupt passiert, bevor man darüber diskutieren kann, wie es sein sollte. Und das ist auch ein bisschen Teil von der Gesellschaft und Demokratie als Voraussetzung, dass sie funktionieren. Dass es da irgendwie so einen Konsens gibt, mit so einem gemeinsamen, wie sagt man, geringsten Nenner, was eigentlich gerade überhaupt vor sich geht.
Aber haben sich nicht im Netz dieselben, mehr oder weniger dieselben Light-Medien auch dir geschlagen? Oder zumindest auch welche herausgebildet?
Ja, Spiegel Online ist natürlich so eine Art Light-Medium, worauf wir alle Bezug nehmen, aber davon abgesehen, gibt es trotzdem auch Leute, die Spiegel Online einfach nicht lesen und dann in ihrer Blase, was auch immer das ist, da gibt es ja verschiedene Arten von Blasen. Also es gibt erstmal ganz viele junge Erwachsene, Jugendliche, die sich für Politik und Nachrichten gar nicht interessieren und dann auch eben keine klassischen Light-Medien in irgendeiner Form konsumieren. Und für die existiert dann einfach der Syrienkrieg. Also es ist einfach nicht in deren Weltsicht irgendwie vorhanden.
War das so früher so sehr viel anders?
Ich glaube schon, dass es immer Zeiten gab, wo eben wirklich ein Großteil der Nationen sich dann vor der Tage schaffte, was sie ermäht hat und so.
Also gut, aber nur weil die Nachricht dir erzählt wird, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass sie bei dir auch verfängt.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen die Voraussetzung, dass überhaupt erst mal, also ist klar, es gab immer Teil der Gesellschaft, die sich nicht für Politik oder den Rest der Gesellschaft großartig interessiert haben, das auf jeden Fall. Aber ich glaube, dass so diese, diese Teile der Gesellschaft, die tatsächlich irgendwie gar keinen Anschluss mehr haben an den Mainstream und das, was diskutiert wird, dass die größer geworden sind durch die Medienvielfalt.
Ja, aber vielleicht bricht sich auch noch irgendwas bahnig. Ich meine, vorher gab es sozusagen gar nicht so viele diversifizierte Outlets und man gab es sich schlicht der Illusion hin, dass dadurch da jetzt irgendwie alle vor der Tagesschau oder meinetwegen noch vor der heutigen Sendung saßen, dass damit sozusagen der gesellschaftliche Konsens auch herbeigeführt worden ist, so einfach per Akklamation. Obwohl eigentlich so wenig davon verfangen hat oder die Bereitschaft zum Ignorieren so groß ausgeprägt war, dass das eben eigentlich gar nicht so war. Und jetzt, wo es eben die alternative Betätigung auch gibt, die dann eben auch tatsächlich ausgelebt wird, aber sich eigentlich in dem Sinne gar nichts verändert hat.
Könnte natürlich sein, aber andererseits, ich glaube, wenn man so ein bisschen sich umfragen und so was, Studien zur Jugend ansieht, da ist es schon so, dass der Teil, der sich so ganz abkoppelt hat von gesellschaftlichen Diskursen, schon gewachsen ist, glaube ich. Also wenn man halt die Möglichkeit schafft, dass Leute sich komplett abkoppeln können, dann werden sie halt auch eher genutzt. Also ich will ja jetzt gar nicht sagen, wir sollen jetzt die Zeit zurückdrehen und alle sollen um 8 Uhr Tagesschau gucken. Aber es ist so ein Trend, den man im Auge haben muss. Ja, wo man zumindest mal nachdenken kann, ob das nur gute Aspekte hat. Also es hat auch immer gute Aspekte, aber es hat eben auch...
Tja, der Journalismus muss also die Herzen wieder zurückgewinnen.
Aber du bist ja dabei. Ja, ich tu, was ich kann, ja.
Ja, haben wir noch was Wichtiges vergessen? Liegt dir noch was am Herzen?
Ja, vielleicht können wir noch kurz darüber sprechen. Nochmal über eine Jeff Jarvis-Theorie. Und zwar die der Verticals. Jeff Jarvis hat schon 2007 den Leitspruch an die Journalisten der Welt herausgebracht. Do what you cover best and link to the rest. Das war so seine Herangehensweise. Und die Idee dahinter ist, durch das Internet haben wir halt diese riesige Vielfalt an Informationen, an Journalisten, die sich mit allen möglichen Themen beschäftigen. Und in der Vergangenheit war es so, dass jede Tageszeitung, jede Regionalzeitung einen neuen Film besprochen hat und seine Theorie dazu ist im Grunde, dass man sagt, jeder sollte sich auf die Spezialgebiete konzentrieren, die er am besten können und die großen Themen können auch von den großen Medien oder von denen, die sich da am besten auskennen oder am längsten covern, die besten Spezialisten haben, von denen übernommen werden. Also muss man eben nicht 300 verschiedene Reviews vom neuen Film anbieten, sondern man kann die drei Filmtheorexperten, die das am besten können, das übernehmen lassen. Dafür kann man sich dann Lokalzeitung den lokalen Themen umso mehr widmen, dass es eben so die Theorie, die dahinter steckt. Und wie gesagt, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, dass er das ausgegeben hat als Parode und ich muss sagen, seitdem habe ich den Trend eigentlich andersherum wahrgenommen. Also ich habe eher wahrgenommen, dass alle immer breiter werden in ihren Themen. Also auch ehemalige Spezialmedien, die relativ spitz waren in ihrer Themenfindung, haben eigentlich sich immer breiter aufgestellt, einfach weil es funktioniert hat, weil die Leute da eben, weil eben derjenige, der sich für Aktien und Anleihen interessiert, oft auch sich für Fußball interessiert und für Boulevard auch und von daher kann man halt einfach die Klickzahlen erhöhen, wenn man dann mehr anbietet, also ein breiteres Themenspektrum.
Warten Sie wieder, die Klickzahlen, aber in gewisser Hinsicht, also was mir gerade als erstes einfiel, was ich auch selber sehr gerne als Quelle verwende, so für meine private Bubble sind Linkblogs. Linkblogs, die halt primär auf anderen Content verweisen, die es aber immer oder häufig mit einem Kommentar versehen, der sehr kurz sein kann, teilweise vielleicht nur ein Wort, ja, was weiß ich, irgendwie so ein Link auf unsere völlig absurde Story und die wird halt auch kommentiert mit irgendwie totally absurd, ja, oder irgendwie oh my god, womit interessanterweise eine ganze Menge gesagt wird, weil man eben dem Link selber einen Kontext verpasst, eine Bewertung mit auf die Reise gibt, man ist quasi auch vorausgelassen, ausgestattet mit so einer Bewertung. Die Bewertung ist aber insofern hochrelevant, weil mir die Person, die hier dieses Link-Blog betreibt, eben über die Zeit mit diesen ganzen Kommentaren sozusagen auch so ein bisschen ans Herz gewachsen ist oder ich zumindest es einschätzen kann. Muss ja gar nicht mal unbedingt derselben Meinung sein, sondern kann auch einer ganz anderen Meinung sein und was für den einen oh my god ist, ist für mich vielleicht schon wiederum dann ganz interessant, ja. Every now and then allerdings gibt es dann in diesem Blog dann auch einen Eigenbeitrag. Der sehr lang ist, also sozusagen ein originärer Blogpost, der dann eben im Spezialgebiet dann eben auch voll einsteigt und so eine Perspektive bietet, die möglichst auch viel andere verlinkte Artikel vorher, die quasi der total der Historie sind, mitreflektiert und eine eigene Analyse mitbeiträgt. Und dazwischen dann auch immer wieder so etwas ausführlichere Zitate aus diesen verlinkten Artikeln, also dass eben nicht nur mit einem Wort was kommentiert wird, sondern dass eben ein oder zwei Absätze zitiert werden, die quasi die Relevanz dieser Verlinkung in dem Moment auch deutlich machen. Sodass man häufig auch nur die Zitate liest und sich merkt so, ah, alles klar, da gab's diesen Aspekt, der wurde so hervorgehoben und später fällt einem das Ding vielleicht erstmal ein und dann fängt man irgendwie an, alles zu lesen, weil man aus irgendwelchen Gründen jetzt nochmal mehr Interesse hat, also man merkt, dass vielleicht das Thema später erst hochkocht und, ah, da war ja schonmal was zu dem Ding, das hatte ich noch gar nicht so auf dem Zeiger, aber ich hab zumindest schonmal so die Essenz wahrgenommen. Also ich finde ja irgendwie ein sehr mächtiges Medium, das finde ich passt ganz gut zu diesem Ansatz, den ihr jetzt hier von Jeff Jarvis zitiert habt.
Es ist natürlich wieder voraus, dass man eine persönliche Bindung zu demjenigen hat, der ja dann kommentiert. Also das kann man glaube ich nicht in dem Maße zu einem Medium jetzt empfinden, wenn das jetzt nicht gerade ein sehr ausgesprochenen, weiß ich nicht, Links oder irgendwie in irgendeiner Form explodiert ist.
Es könnte zum Beispiel auch ein Journalist sein, das ist zum Beispiel etwas, was mir fehlt. Mir fehlt ein Journalist, der so einen Link-Block für Journalismus macht und mir würde da jetzt einfach in Deutschland nichts einfangen. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht wäre das für mich viel, viel, viel wertvoller. Jemand, der dadurch auch immer wieder neue Quellen mit einbringt, die ich so gar nicht auf dem Zeiger habe, weil ja klar, ich lese vielleicht bei drei oder vier oder fünf Portalen oder klicke auch mal auf Google News, um so ein bisschen breiter zu kommen, aber bei Google News, da weiß ich, da ist es so wie eine Maschine und da wäre mir dann auch sozusagen irgendeiner dieser Artikel schafft sozusagen, der primär Verlinkte zu sein, hätte aber auch der Zweite sein können. Aber irgendwie sind die sowieso nur deshalb zusammen, weil sie irgendwie mehr oder weniger alle das Gleiche erzählen, weil es vielleicht auf derselben DPA-Meldung basiert oder was auch immer. In dem Moment, wo aber ein Journalist das machen würde und sagt so, ja, hier, da, bei Spiegel Bericht über das, hier, bei Zeit Online, aber Bericht auf das, hier, Züricher, Tageblatt, dieses und hier mal was aus den USA und da mal was. Und damit sozusagen so eine informierte Sicht darstellt, also der Journalist viel mehr als Interpret des journalistischen Zyklus ist und damit auch sozusagen jemand, der mich auf die Räume... Also ich fände das mal ein geiles Dienstwerk.
Aber der müsste sich ja für alles interessieren, das müsste jetzt jemand sein, der den kompletten Nachrichten überblickt.
Ja gut, aber das machen doch Journalisten auch.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also ich meine, das würde ich ja geradezu erwarten von einem Journalisten, dass er sozusagen die eigene Branche ganz anders im Blick hat. Mal ehrlich, ihr guckt euch das doch an, was die anderen schreiben. Ja gut, warum dann nicht dabei auch gleich verlinken? Warum nicht auch ein bisschen kommentieren? Warum nicht auch mal zitieren? Und warum nicht auch gerade zu diesem sich daraus ergebenden, wie sagt man so schön, Narrativ einen eigenen Kommentar geben? Sowas findet sich ja. So ein Stephan Niggemeier, der immer schön ja auch auf allen rumhaut und auch viel verlinkt. Der bloggt aber auch nur dann, wenn er da viel zu zu sagen hat. Aber dazwischen durch einfach mal so einen Artikel so für sich stehen zu lassen, oder sowas fehlt. Also ich fände das sehr schön, weil es genau dieser Aussage, also nicht, weil es jetzt die Aussage von Jeff Jarvis ist, weil ich da relativ, weiß nicht, mir ist, wenn ich sage, mir egal, er definiert jetzt auch nicht irgendwie meine Weltsicht, fände ich eigentlich mal einen ganz schönen Ansatz.
Stimmt, ja. Also wäre das dann für dich ja ein Meta-Blog über Nachrichten oder über Journalismus? Also über Nachrichten. Nachrichten, ja.
Also es könnte alles Mögliche sein. Wenn mich jetzt sozusagen Journalismus als solcher auch interessiert, würde mich das natürlich auch an Journalismus heranführt. Es könnte aber auch einen ganz anderen zu, es könnte sich auch im Bereich Umwelt, es könnte sich im Bereich was auch immer wählen, aber sozusagen die eigentlichen News-Quellen überhaupt erst mal hervorzuholen, leicht zu kommentieren und ab und zu auch mal eine komplett eigene Sicht auf die Themenwelten selber zu bringen. Da ist halt mal ein Artikel über Umweltpolitik in Deutschland oder keine Ahnung, was mit drin und der Rest bedient sich eben anderer Quellen und bringt immer wieder mal neue Quellen. Fertig schön. Ja, schönes Produkt. Wäre mir dann auch was wert. Weil ja eine Meinung damit rüberkommt und weil die Meinung eigentlich das unbezahlbarste Gut ist, finde ich so, weil das ja sozusagen das Endprodukt aller Nachrichten ist, das, was sich da am Ende herausgebildet hat. Viele Leute kaufen ja Consultants ein, damit die ihre Meinung, die sie sich da gebildet haben, für teuer Geld...
Im Journalismus sagt man eigentlich auch, eine Meinung hat jeder. Also es kommt auch mal sehr darauf an, wie fundiert diese Meinung dann letztlich ist und dann kommt es auch wieder sehr auf die Person an. Das wäre halt wirklich so eine Sache, die dann jemand machen müsste, den du auch persönlich dann irgendwie schätzt und dessen Meinung du auch wertschätzt und dann wäre das natürlich ein sehr wertvolles Angebot.
Genau, ich schätze ihn natürlich über dieses Angebot, das bedingt sich so ein bisschen. Gibt es denn noch andere Phänomene, die du aus diesem Zitat noch ableiten würdest?
Also ich glaube, dass, kurz überlegen, ich sehe den Trend geht er in die andere Richtung. Ich glaube aber, dass er da wirklich eine Wahrheit sagt und ich glaube auch, dass es noch mehr spitzere Zielgruppen geben könnte, wenn eine andere Form des Geschäftsmodells eben gefunden wird. Also das ist auch wieder das Thema Crowdfunding. Also wenn es entsprechend Leute gibt, die ja bereits sind, auch möglicherweise höhere Geldbeträge zu bezahlen, dann könnten auch noch ganz, ganz spezielle Dinge journalistisch aufgearbeitet werden, für die sich heute kein Mensch interessiert, wofür aber dann eben wenige ein sehr großes Interesse haben. Das ist dann so eine Frage von Angebot und Nachfrage. Also wenn sich keiner um irgendein Thema kümmert, es aber Leute gibt, die sich dafür sehr stark interessieren, dann sind sie möglicherweise auch bereit, dafür entsprechend höher mehr Geld zu bezahlen. Zum Bereich Crowdfunding zum Beispiel. Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass Journalismus in der Zukunft deutlich mehr Bereiche, mehr in die Ecken geht, also dass nicht jede Regionalzeitung nur über den Besuch von Merkel bei Obama schreibt und dann irgendwie es 300 verschiedene Versionen von diesem Besuch gibt, die alle im Grunde das selbe sagen, sondern dass alle viel mehr noch in die Extreme, in die Ecken, in den hyperlokalen Bereich gehen. Das ist so ein Abbiechen.
Also die Rhein-Zeitung ist glaube ich so ein Beispiel, die sich auch extrem auf ihren Local Shit konzentrieren, damit ja eigentlich auch ganz gut erfolgreich sind. So eine neue Fokussierung.
Ja, zumindest haben sie im Netz eine ziemlich hohe Wahrnehmung, wie das jetzt wirtschaftlich aussieht. Weiß ich nicht. Wobei, in den Regional-Zeitungen geht es insgesamt auch relativ gut. Also die haben diesen Wandel noch am wenigsten bisher zu spüren bekommen.
Ja, Stephan, was meinst du? Jetzt haben wir es glaube ich.
Jetzt kann man es schießen, ja.
Also es ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, ein Experiment gewesen, hier das Gespräch. Ich fand das ganz interessant, aber einfach mal so ein paar die Aspekte, die derzeit diskussionswürdig sind, aufzubringen. Wir betrachten hier etwas, was irgendwie extrem im Fluss ist, was permanenter Veränderung, veränderter Wahrnehmung auch unterlegen ist. Ja, aber dann beenden wir mal hier den Überblick über Online-Journalismus. Vielen Dank. Ja. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei CRE. Es geht auch bald weiter.